Happy duty!
Thank you so much for the Tony Captain!
Thank you!
Wow, it's been so long since I last streamed!
Definitely for me it was not...
20 minutes ago!
Not at all!
I totally didn't get changed in that time.
We missed you!
Wow.
You guys are too much.
Hishashiburi!
You missed me?
You missed me!
Today is a collab!
So, it'll be me.
I'm going in order of people on the thumbnail.
Oymo!
Mogu!
Dust go.
They are... they are...
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna click out of the game and it's gonna stop the music.
They are in Discord right now, so I should probably join.
I should probably stop being a little introvert and talking to you guys.
Are we there yet?
So I'm going to join them.
Um, I'm coming.
I'm going to tell them and be like, Oh, let me, let me, let me socializing.
Whoa, yeah.
It's my first time collabing with everybody, but I've been friends with everybody for quite a long time.
funny that it's our first time collabing like actually me and Dusko like we hang out very not I wouldn't say often but like if we're in the same place together we hang out together so like I see her at many conventions and events and we've gone to Disney together and stuff so two ghosts in one stream I know!
And Vogue was a ghost we're extra haunted yeah yeah So, yeah, I'm going to go, I'm going to join now.
Bye, everybody.
Oh, why did Oimo say no?
I don't think Oimo wants to collab with me.
I think she hates me.
I'm coming in anyway.
Oh, my God.
We should run.
Run, run, run, run.
Thank you, Aklaan, Mint Slime.
Me, howdy, Mint.
Me, howdy.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I think Oimo's about to pass away.
Can you resurrect her?
Can you give her mouth to mouth, please?
Why is she about to pass away?
Wait.
Because you walked in the room.
You just have to affect the people.
Oimo is not in the call.
She doesn't recognize my existence.
This is great.
She's going great.
It's going awesome.
This is already going so great.
She doesn't hear me.
I'm gonna...
No, I can hear you.
I can hear you.
Just why aren't you in the Discord?
Oh my gosh, is that Mogu wants to play with me?
Oh my god, Carol!
Oh my god!
No!
Wait, the invite disappeared.
I didn't- Wait, you can change their skin color?
Wait, let me share my screen.
This is insane.
Oh wait, I can hear you in the game, huh?
down in the game.
I think so.
Send me another invite, please.
Wait, why can't I...
Why can't I send it?
Dusty, you can use it in the invite!
Yeah, I like...
Oh.
It's like great outfit.
Why?
Why game hate me?
Does the audio doubled right now?
Yes.
It is.
Oh, it says that...
Are we gonna talk in the game?
It says she's in the game.
Do you want to talk in the game or do you want to talk?
talk here.
Talking real live.
Talking the game or talking real live.
Oh, my mic is... I can turn on push to talk or whatever.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, give, give.
I just turned off the audio.
Oh, you guys want to be...
I'm going to be old.
I'm going to be an old dude.
Oh, my God.
This guy is shaking.
I've got Arthur right.
Uh-oh.
Sorry.
The invite is not working.
Wait, I'm going to quit the game and restart the game.
It says, yeah, because it says that you're in here.
It does?
Oh, does it?
Oh, maybe I should.
Oh, no.
And then now it's gone.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Let me try.
Wait, hold up.
How did you guys switch your avatar?
I'm still listening.
I've always been.
It's like the left and right on the bottom of your character.
Like the arrows.
The less than greater than.
You went to college.
Did I?
Did you?
I did.
I certainly did.
There's in-game.
Let me actually, let me see if it's the game registered that I bought.
Hold up.
I forgot to cover my screen.
Maybe it's me.
Maybe I'm gonna, should I leave?
Oh, it's...
Did I kick everyone out?
Yeah, I kicked everyone out.
No!
Oops!
Okay, um, should I...
Should I try hosting or does someone else want to try hosting and inviting everyone?
Let me try.
Would that work?
Yes.
Okay, I'm able to make a- Okay.
I think you just- Oh, joy.
Ah!
Oh!
What the hell?
Here!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, I changed me.
Oh, I have to be an old lady.
Why- oh, you're the- You're the driver, Duska!
Oh god!
You can tell that to Babo.
He will lose his mind!
Wait!
He says I'm terrible at driving.
Who's the best driver here?
How many of us can drive?
I can drive!
I can drive?
Oh, it's only me?
Oh, yeah, you're Echo, you're Double.
Am I?
Double-oo.
Yeah, Double-oo.
Oh my god, you're so cute.
Get in the car, shiny!
Wait, is it only me that's double-ing?
Am I doubled?
Yes.
I am?
Oh, what?
Oh, no, I think...
Mogus doubled?
Am I doubled now?
Oh, one at a time.
Oh.
Okay, no, the myth is good.
Yippee!
Can you hear me, Sunny?
Peanut climbs.
Okay, you're good.
I don't hear you.
How do you change your character?
I can't with the arrow keys I don't have the paid version of that way.
Oh, that's probably why.
Oh my god, you look like me Man paid a win.
I made a win You've got to be guy green shirt.
I want to be a little grandma grandpa.
You don't you look like an emo kid Do I that's how I look like a real one You know what I look like?
Yeah!
Am I emo?
Oh, oh, no!
What's your my space, Katie?
Krosky Koon.
Would I be in your top five?
Yes, always.
We're gonna put Babo second.
Actually, we're gonna put him fifth.
Wait, where's me?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm like number nine.
No!
I'll take it.
Number nine.
Nine for baka.
Foot lettuce.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That's two very different brain rods.
Foot lettuce.
Oh my god.
Only the boomer otaku know the nine.
It's true.
The nine with the circle.
Yeah.
I bet Mogu doesn't know this.
Oh wait.
You can be a grandma if you press the middle button, Mogu.
Middle button.
If you want to drive.
You know what?
Wait, what?
While passenger while driving.
While I'm not a passenger though.
Whenever the grandma opens her mouth, it's like really terrifying.
It's like...
Ah!
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
Okay, we can customize the car.
You can customize the car?
Yeah.
Oh, never mind.
Don't let me customize the car.
You lied to me, kid.
You give me these options.
Ah.
Lame.
Okay, it says level select.
Oh, we can play Evening at Grandma's or Neil Peel's Deals on Wheels.
Has anyone played this game?
Do we know what we're doing?
I got no idea.
I think that's the best part, right?
Yeah, we gotta discover how to drive together.
Yeah!
Okay, you guys ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's try this out.
Oh, it's spooky.
Oh, my God.
What?
What are we hearing?
What the heck?
Is that you?
Is that me?
Instead of rushing us out the door, Grandma and Grandpa had us all crowded around the TV.
Oh my gosh, it's so scary.
They'd heard about it, Bingo Hall.
They were in awe.
A sweaty local car salesman was blowing their minds with his latest no-catch government-funded offer.
Oh, mucho texto.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Holy crap!
Jesus, why aren't you dyslexic to read this?
Oh, who skipped it?
Oh my god, skipped it!
I think I accidentally skipped it.
I'll go down.
That's okay.
Right, right, right, space.
Oh, I'm- it's so wobbly.
I'm gonna get so sick.
I'm so- I'm so old.
Who's next to me?
Who are you?
Oh, I'm in the middle.
I'm in the middle seat.
You're in the middle?
Hi!
This is me, so neat.
Are you guys all in the back?
Oh, I guess I'm driving.
Yeah, you're driving.
grandma i can't see it go grandma can you go in the mix tape i can't see anything grandma i want to listen to the mix tape as brittany's here i'm getting car sick okay oh geez oh god wait i can wait i just grabbed this tape from you but now i can't get rid of this tape what do i do with this oh i can change the ac it's yeah it's blasted grandma blast it Okay,
how do I move?
I think one of the options is that if you go into options and then press gameplay and then center interact, I think it helps with the motion sickness.
So I said gameplay center interact on?
Yeah, center interact on.
Why is it getting so steamy in here?
Oh my god.
It's like that scene in Titanic.
Yeah.
Oh, I think we're on fire.
We're on fire.
We haven't even started the game.
I can't even see.
I don't even know.
Go.
E.
I can't see anything either.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I think I'm going.
I don't know.
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
We died?
No.
This might be hell.
This might be hell, actually.
I can't see I'm just in spots Oh, we switched spots somehow I'm all I can't see Wait, are we actually dying?
I'm gonna Get out of here Have you just had it?
Can you pat yourself?
Roll?
It's cloudy in here I can't see Why is there teeth?
What was that?
Oh my god I forgot to stay real Uh-oh.
What's going on?
Oh!
Grandma, what are you doing?
Come on.
I don't know.
I think I have dementia.
Turn the air down.
I think that's why it's foggy.
Oh, turn the air down.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I can see it again.
Vogu, are you okay?
Oh, it's cold.
The physically would just let me move.
How am I supposed to get- Why am I derogating?
Who's that dude?
Why are you- Oh, I've got it.
I got it.
Okay.
Why did- Oh, I switched these.
Awesome.
Hi, Oima.
I'm on fire.
I can't see.
I think you're still in the parking lot.
It says to go for her.
Yeah, I think you're- Can you reverse?
It says go break and that's it.
Try pressing on the back key like a You know.
Oh, I'm gonna roll down the windows.
Yeah, keep rolling them down.
You can do it for both sides.
Yeah, you guys have to do the error.
Sorry, that was me.
I had a burrito for lunch.
Are you Moku?
Yeah, I'm Moku.
I'm on your left.
Thank you.
I don't know where to look.
I'm Minto.
Whoa.
I'm on fire right now.
I'm like that dogen panel of the two garus next to the boy.
Oh, oh, I found it.
No steering wheel, no problem.
I mean, look at you reading.
I don't, I can't even see over the dashboard.
Yeah, that's the game.
That's the point.
That was the other guy's cheating you.
We all know where to go.
go top left guys oh there's a parking ticket on my booty maybe maybe we need that to get out oh okay i can't reach it though someone needs to get it someone needs to yeah someone reach behind my booty grab the ticket from her booty i can't get it what do you guys have a tape in your mouth i can't get rid of the tape for some reason i got it i got it thank you oh my god It's been stopped there.
I don't know why I'm trying, girl.
Why is she on fire still?
Should I?
Oh, how do I get...
Oh, okay, thank you.
Should we reset?
No, I think we got this, right?
You guys are supposed to backseat me, right?
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay, so turn the car on.
Is it not on?
The car is on.
Okay, and then...
Go to the left.
Go left.
the left oh yeah i got it got it got into the left i am i'm pressing the i'm pressing the gas
is it oh oh it's moving it's moving oh we're moving we're moving oh you need to wear your get me out of your cool
oh the privacy i'm trying to draw here
I think go to your right.
Go to my right.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm actually dead.
Go to my right.
I'm pressing.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep going.
It's inching.
Oh.
I'm just, I'm in the cock seat now.
The what?
Is it good?
Am I good yet?
Wait, wait, wait.
You're in the where?
I'm cool.
I'm in the cock seat.
I'm cocking.
What do you mean you're in the cut seat?
You're in the front with the big, you're idiots.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh, maybe you have to reverse and then turn right.
There's no reverse.
Oh.
Can you turn to the left then?
Can you just try?
Yeah.
Yeah, just a little bit to the left.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We're pushing.
We're moving.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Okay, keep going.
Keep going.
Well, I...
would be ideal but yeah right right like push our way out you know like use other cars as some kind of like a bumper oh wait there is this reverse type of waymo what do you see oh you found it i had to do the prindle okay i think for me there you go there you go okay go to the right now okay go straight oh
No, it's me!
It's me!
I'm dead!
It's dead!
Okay, okay.
There is death in this game?
Yeah.
Why am I driving?
This is not helping my Asian situation.
I'm just...
Okay.
This is not helping the stereotype.
Okay, reverse a little bit.
Oh, I can see now, I don't know.
Yeah, you're back in the...
You're back in the...
Oh, geez.
What's happening to me?
Oh, come on the first.
That's where I was.
Girl, enjoy the cutscene.
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
Oh, we're at a checkpoint.
Let's go.
Okay, stop.
And then go a little forward.
A little forward.
Okay.
Yeah.
A little forward.
Just a little bit.
Like this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, turn right.
Turn right.
Turn left.
Yeah, turn left.
No, no, no, no.
Keep going!
Okay!
No!
Oh, jeez.
Why are you turning the light on?
Why are you turning the light on, grandma?
It's not gonna help you see better.
I didn't turn the light on.
Can you not back on?
Oh, no, you can.
You can.
Okay, good, good, good.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Can we get Charles on our way home?
Yeah, if we can figure out how to drive the I see nothing.
I'm in the...
Do you mean?
I'm underneath the car right now.
Where is Mint?
Where's my wife?
She's looking in the box.
Oh, here I am.
Oh, there I go.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, thank you!
Are you guys back?
Yeah, I'm back.
Oh, what's that?
There you go.
Okay, where do I go now?
The right?
Um, we're still back up a little bit?
The left or the right?
Um, go to the right.
Oh, oh, you guys wanted to go there?
Yeah, there's arrows.
Where's the arrow?
Oh, I was just saying- My bet, my bet, my bet.
Turn the reverse.
I was just saying go anywhere.
Man, this is how you see when you draw.
I can't see shit.
What?
Oh, okay, go straight.
Why am I taking strays?
You can't be taking strays if you're also in the car with me.
Wow, I hope these people have insurance.
And then...
Turn left!
90 degrees.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you're gonna go right.
Yeah, turn right!
Turn right!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Right?
Yeah, turn right.
Reverse!
Reverse, reverse!
Oh my god, floor it grandma floor it Wait, hold on.
Floor it.
Okay.
Floor it?
Yeah floor it right.
I want Mogu to die I want her to be in the death seat Only two people in here are not ghosts
Wasn't it awesome?
Oh, wait, why is my scene down?
Oh, it is down.
Do I go?
Where do I go, right?
Left, left, left, left, left.
Oh, you...
Where are we?
Like this?
Oh, wrong way.
Grandma.
Wrong way?
Come on.
Okay, you back off?
I'm not even the oldest one here.
What are you talking about?
I'm insane.
We're in the same time frame.
Okay, left now, left now.
Left now.
Push.
Why are the windshield wipers on?
Oh, we're gonna hit the wall.
Floor it.
This is hard to look good.
Now back up a little, but go to your right when you back up.
Okay.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Now floor it.
Floor it straight.
straight okay turn right a little bit i
found the gas pedal i was randomly pressing it and i just lost it this oh my god okay go right right uh-huh you gotta reverse a little bit you gotta reverse to the left oh sorry i was wrong
backwards okay go straight go straight floor it floor it wait isn't those like whoa whoa oh yeah nice nice oh we need a coin we need a coin oh I got one I got one did you guys where do we put the coin I have one right now I can throw it in your mouth grandma open wide i threw it to you open wide where do i put it uh just drive forward drive straight holy yeah drive straight floor actually if you go fast enough i don't think we'll have to pay okay so let me back up and then just go forward we'll pay it later yeah we can pay later yeah yeah they're gonna mail us stuff we'll just ignore it i can't go back can you turn the windshield wipers off i'm getting over i don't know overstimulated back here okay how do i so i go forward yep yep yep floor i'm flooring it wait i'm going anywhere wait why don't we oh why am i
What?
Why am I the grandma?
Wait, what?
What's happening?
I need to go, I need a girl.
Ow!
There you go.
There's two girls now.
Oops.
What's the print?
Oh, this one?
Which one's, what's this do?
What does that do?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that's reverse.
Okay.
What's this do?
Nothing, okay, that might be park.
Okay.
All right, I'm gonna twist it.
Oh, you need to go right.
Right, y'all.
Right.
Yeah, you have to get up a little.
Back up a little?
All right, yeah, you're literally like ramming into another car.
That's fine, they'll cover it.
Are you guys cold?
Go straight.
Oh.
Yeah, just a little bit.
A little chilly.
Oh my God, oh my God.
I don't want to see that happening.
Oh, how do I turn the...
Oh!
Wait, why am I driving?
Oh my god!
If you click the yellow thing next to the steering wheel, it changes person, it looks like.
Oh, the keys?
Yeah!
I'm on fire.
Yeah, why are you on fire?
Yeah, you are fire because you're so hot.
Girl, that's exactly how you use this.
Yeah, I know.
I want one trick wonder.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Wait, who's driving?
I'm driving.
Go!
Go straight!
Wait, who's this?
Who is this?
I'm in the middle.
Who are you?
Oh, you need a coin.
Can we...
Oh, here's a coin, grandma.
Grandpa.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sonny.
Oh, okay.
Sonny.
You're welcome.
I like how he's holding it with both of his hands.
How do I pay?
Oh, look at him.
He's so gentle with it.
How do I pay?
On the right, I think.
On the...
Do I just eat the coin out?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'll pick it up.
Yeah, why not?
They'll understand what it means.
Okay, I did it.
Does that work?
No, I'm flooring it.
I think it's on the right.
There's like a toll thing on the right, I think.
Oh, no.
Oh.
I don't see it.
I can kind of see it.
Can you hear the skull?
Let me roll down the window.
Oh, that, and I rolled that up.
Okay.
Am I reversing?
No.
Let me see.
Now, yes you are.
Oh, oh.
Now you are.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I see it.
It's right there.
Oh, I saw it.
Okay, okay.
Where is it?
Oh, I can do it.
I can do it.
Oh, nice.
Give a coin.
Who has a coin?
I don't have one.
Wait, I think we got rid of all the coins.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
Oh, we fucked up already.
What's this?
Can we put that in there?
Nope.
Can we put this tape in there?
Uh.
tapes oh my daughter mix tape it's priceless are we softball oh no we already fucked up crank the heat let's burn this place down we're taking them with us yeah I never felt more alive
of us was like oh there's a coin oh yeah i know okay wait is there a coin no i don't see no i don't see any can we leave the car and get it i know all right oh oh what happened oh i i if you press arrow keys it like gives you direct oh but i didn't need the coin wait what wait that's so nice oh i can't wait you found the coin yay that coin is in the queen Wait,
give it to me.
Where's it?
I have it.
Right there.
No, that's the- Oh, I got it on the seat.
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Got it.
I got it.
I'm stretching.
Okay, do I just throw it in?
Yeah, Dub.
Oh, did it make it?
It's party turning a seat.
Oh, it's on the seat right.
It's on the right side of the passenger seat.
I can't reach it.
I don't see it.
I'm not going to see it.
wait wait wait what's this oh i can't see it oh we're sitting on the right it's on the right side of the passenger seat um how is this the hardest part i don't know um you see an evo kid no no yeah i don't think you can see anything come on grandma you don't even know our names No!
You guys kind of like all the same to me.
I'm hurt.
Except one of you.
My feelings.
Not just a phase, grandma.
Wait, yeah, if you drive forward and like slam into something, it'll jostle it.
Oh!
I got it!
Okay, now back up.
We can just switch seats with Moku and then throw it out the window.
Yeah, oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, too much, too much!
Oh, she doesn't know how to break.
Oh, she...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Um, almost there.
Dusty.
Okay, okay, wait, we're ramming it.
Just a little?
I mean, we have to go back a little bit, right?
I'm playing...
I'm playing Step Mania.
What song are you playing?
Max 300.
If I...
Oh.
Just back up a little bit?
No, no, no, back up a little bit.
Yeah, just back up just a tad.
No good?
More?
Good.
You're good?
You're good.
Oh, oh..
Am I good now?
Uh, forward.
Forward?
Yep.
Okay, okay.
A little more, a little more.
A little more.
Oh, yeah.
Did it open?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Did it?
Floor.
Wait, did it open?
I can't see shit.
It's too cold up here.
Neither can we.
Put the windshield wipers on.
No, it's like that thing where it fogs on the inside.
me i missed it but wait wait wait i have another point i have another point you're right uh okay okay.
Okay don't aim so high back up back up yeah back up grandma ah geez a little more a little bit oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Oh, I do this?
Do I risk it?
Risk it for the biscuit.
Kobe!
I missed.
Wait, did you make it?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, it's back up.
Back up, I see the coin in the car.
Yeah, yeah, they're in the front.
Yeah.
Back up, back up, like this.
Back up, back up.
Oh, uh, can you see through the flames?
Kobe.
Yeah, I think you missed again.
Can I do it?
I missed it again?
Yeah.
Well, there was like a ticket.
I don't know where that went.
I missed again You missed again How many pennies are on the floor?
Wait, do we have to put the ticket in the bird?
Oh, do we?
Where is the ticket though?
That's so complicated.
Oh my god, where is it?
Is it this?
No, I think we're just missing the coin.
Kobe Oh,
it went back into the car.
We're fine.
Okay, good, good.
Try again.
Kobe.
One more.
Post me too late.
Third time's the charm.
Colby.
Yeah, I think that's the charm.
Minto.
Did it work?
Did it go?
Wait, it didn't spawn back in the car though.
What the heck?
Oimo.
It worked?
Oh, no.
It's up your ass.
It's on my butt.
I can't grab, I can't grab him.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, go.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's a little bath.
more back a little tiny bit back a little tiny little bit into the right like that more wait we're going forward somehow how are we how are we oh i'm not i'm backing up oh like this um oh mogu uh wait did that work uh no did it i can't see remember uh like the did it work guys no the coin disappeared oh
There's no coin anymore.
Oh, I see it, I see a coin.
Here you go.
Oh, where did it go?
Oh, there it is.
Thank you.
Dusko.
Oh, man.
I think I see the coin.
It's under the seat.
Me too.
Did it work?
Oh, my God.
Wait, can you reverse it?
A little bit.
Maybe.
Yeah, reversal if it's close to the plate.
I think we're too far maybe.
It doesn't look like it's going that far.
I feel like something must be missing.
Oh, oh, nice, nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
And go forward like...
Okay, nice, nice.
Go forward to the right a little.
Yeah.
The windows roll down, right?
Down, it's down.
Yeah, it's down.
Like that?
Like this?
Oh, that's pretty good, that's...
Is that good?
I can't get the coin.
Oh, it's by you.
It's by you.
Yeah.
It's by me?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's two.
Oh, yeah, here.
Oh, you don't want to do it?
You could be the gamer.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, wait.
Reverse a little bit.
Toby.
Got it?
No.
I have a coin.
Let me try.
Yeah, there's more coins.
Oh, okay.
Switch, switch.
I'll switch.
Yep.
And go forward.
right yeah just a little bit how do i switch with you see oh there we go okay yeah it's too far i think okay i got this you got this you got this i used to be a basketball manager manager right yeah i used to because i like slum dunk so much oh i'm gonna say you read kuroko no basket and that's when you said you were a manager i did read kuroko on the basket too okay that's how you just determined it are you good no i'm a little bit not a little bit i think this is too far okay oh my god dude i'm like the worst driver in this car i think i don't think oh oh close close so close okay okay and uh forward forward oh my god give me a touch forward forward Oh,
you need to go straight, you know, you know how to do that.
I never went straight in my entire life.
Have your coin ready.
That's it.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, how do I do this?
Okay, how do I switch with you?
I don't even know which paddle is which paddle.
Oh, oh.
Did you shoot it?
Oh.
Is it glint?
is it bugs because it's like it's like stopping i think we're just bad i could try switching switch do you want to try switching arm arm do you want um okay wait wait wait wait let me try driving yeah yeah how do i switch press the yellow thing press the yellow car yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay okay yeah all right i'm in the car Okay,
kids, where you want to go?
Oh, I want to make Nuggies.
No, I can't, kids.
Where does this land?
Like a coin gold.
Uh, wait.
This is reverse.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're just...
Are we reversing or how is this?
You have to, we're sideways.
We're facing right at the coin thingy.
Yeah, the coin machine.
Why won't it reverse?
Reverse?
Why won't- You have to switch the Prindle.
Oh!
This is- no, this is forward.
Okay.
What's a Prindle?
That's what it's called.
That's what it's called, yeah.
That's what it's called!
What's a Prindle?
P-R-D-L.
P-R-O-O-O-O.
P-R-N-D-L.
Wait, hold up.
It's closer to, um, Dusty.
It's close to Dusty.
Where are we?
Oh!
I'll be facing backwards though, no?
Did- I don't think I can make that.
Hold on, kids.
Hold on.
Grandma, please.
I'm turning our hazards on.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh.
How do I get?
How do you go?
Okay.
This way.
It's harder to look, right?
I'm going to floor it.
Floor it.
Oh.
Okay.
Ran to a wall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
We got this.
Okay.
Reverse.
It's the five-point turn.
Legend.
We're like sandwiched in between cars.
Oh, no!
Yeah, you're...
You're sandwiched between, like, literally a car and a wall.
Yeah!
Oh, gosh, okay.
You had to do that thing where you had to move forward, then back up, then move, then forward, then back up.
Yeah.
Okay, we might be going backwards, but it's just believe.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, you made a U-turn?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, we're fine.
Get back there.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I know how to do this.
Okay.
Looking good, looking good.
Okay, all right.
Wait, you're kind of gaming.
I know how to drive, that's why.
Oh my god, let's go!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
Dude, if we ever were doing a road trip together, we're all fucked.
I'm too
Okay, okay, okay, back up Yeah, I'll be like Why do you put somebody dumbass bitches in the same car?
Okay, okay Alright, alright Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa Oh, that's pretty good, that's pretty good Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, okay, okay, okay Forward a little Just a little bit Okay, forward a little The steering wheel Like, totally It spins It does, it does spin It's so fucking awful.
Go again, go again, go again.
Is that good or no?
Oh no?
Oh my god.
Archer, it's like two to three hours long.
We're literally going to be here for two to three hours.
This is the final boss.
This is the first boss.
Wait.
The windows down?
No, no, you just put it up.
No, that's what I'm saying.
It like when you throw it, it acts like it hits against the window.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got it.
You got it?
We gotta go straight.
I believe in you.
Straight.
All right, Grandma.
Like just straight, straight to the right.
That's right.
Oh, you're good.
You're good.
A little bit to your right.
Just a slight right.
Yeah.
You're doing it.
You're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Kobe.
It just, I don't know.
Hey kids.
I'm trying.
A great.
Wait.
This way.
Oh, remember to bring some change if you choose Neil for your next set of wheels.
We will lock you in the slot.
If you try to leave without paying except in the invoice.
How do you pay?
Wait, can we just leave?
Yeah, can we leave?
I don't know.
I'm okay with committing crimes.
I'm old.
I'll never.
They'll never.
They'll never catch me.
I'll be never before I finish.
Am I close?
No, you're nowhere close.
Who said right?
Oh, stop!
Oh, back up just a little bit.
Oh, my god, so close.
Just a little bit.
Like, like that.
You're good.
Keep going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Do it?
Floor!
Oh, I'm reversing.
Wait, hold up.
We did that one.
We told we did that.
Yeah!
We're free!
I'm free!
Oh my god!
Oh, who's that?
I think he ran into another car and your grandson is, I think his neck is broken.
Who are you?
Oh my god oh I am going berserk oh I guess you got a kid We're good we're good does anyone want to anyone want to be the driver now Okay I could try okay okay that's me oh oh let's go I'm up I don't know how to get out of here actually are there arrows Is left go forward or right go forward?
Right, right, right.
It's like you said you knew how to drive.
Oymo, she doesn't know how to drive.
Left is brake.
Yeah, left is brake.
He is go fast.
And I reverse using this?
Yep.
The Prindle.
Yes.
The middle?
The middle is back?
No.
This is back?
Oymo, you never drove in a car before in your life?
Okay, we're going way back.
We're going back into the garage.
I think we're running over people.
Wait, hold up.
Okay, forward?
Oh, okay, okay.
I think we're running over people.
That's fine.
Yeah, what are we running over?
Yeah.
Why are you so bumpy?
Okay, right, right, right!
Hard, right.
I got dunked out of my seat.
Oh, yeah, you did.
Okay.
Right, right, right, right.
Right, right, right, go, go.
That's straight.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Come on, grandpa.
But once in your life, don't go straight.
Oh, grandpa, grandpa.
Like, crank that wheel.
Oh, that's close.
That's close.
Drift!
Oh, wait, wait, hold that working back up.
Yeah, you're gaming.
Just go backwards, keep going backwards.
Oh, that's not backwards.
That's not backwards.
We're back to where we love these cars.
Okay.
Right, right, right, right.
Hard right, hard right, hard right, hard right!
Hard right, hard right!
Where are we?
Uh, back up and then go right.
Yeah, you're good, you're good, you're good?
Right.
Oh!
Oh, you turned on the light.
You okay?
Hey, who died?
Hey, who are you?
Hey, come back.
Okay, uh, okay.
Okay.
And then go right.
Right, right.
You, right.
You're fine.
You got to.
Which way are we supposed to go?
To the right.
There's a- oh wait, but there's arrows pointing left.
Maybe that's for the other side when we get out of this door.
Oh, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
Where are we even trying to go?
Oh, no.
It says right.
It says come on in.
Drive through the doors.
Drive through the door.
Where?
Okay.
Right, right, right.
Right, right.
Oh, right, right.
Oh, oh, oh.
Grandpa, stop!
Grandpa, you're sitting on me!
Again, I...
I know that's meant.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
This is so stressful.
It does say come on in.
I think you just go inside.
Yeah, we just go inside.
Meals, peals, peals on wheels.
Go inside and pregnant the store.
Okay, I'm gonna go right.
Give them another car baby.
left yeah a car baby is that like a it's like a gas oh you gotta you gotta back up sweetie sweetie you gotta back up we heart is we hurt honey honey please reverse yeah please am i not backing up no no you're not yeah the lever the lever needs to be back i think the prindle the The perindos gotta be bad.
Prendos gotta be bad.
The jerk dad.
That's not the perindos.
I'm gonna hide these people.
Okay.
Are we out of gas?
That's a thing?
No.
Is that a thing?
I don't think so.
I think this is an electric car.
Is, no, okay.
I don't think this is an electric car.
The cyber truck.
It's a cyber truck.
Am I reversing?
you're no you're not no you're not we haven't moved no yeah it's we're pretty stuck i'm gassing it no okay you want someone else try driving okay okay okay no no everything looks right oh wait why we reversed so hard i ice cubed no way grandma grandma please i'm frozen Oh my god,
are you cold?
I'm, I'm, oh.
Oh.
Oh god, oh god, it's all going to shit.
It's all going to shit.
Get Oibo out of the car, out of the sea.
Oh, sevens.
Wait, are we not going forward?
No.
I think you're holding on to me.
You're like, you're throwing me right.
Oh, hi.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I'm not going forward.
I don't know where we're going.
I can't see shit.
It's cold in this car.
I'm frozen.
Grandma, turn on the heat.
Grandma, turn on.
Grandma, put me back in the back seat.
She's just gonna get colder.
Oh, hell yeah.
Oh, fire.
The best way to melt the ice is with fire.
Uh, your grand, one of your grandkids are, you're stepping on your grandkids right now.
Oh, geez.
Oh, I love, oh.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Guys, the pedal came off.
It's hell.
I'm slipping out of the car, grandma, please.
I'm out of the door.
Grandma, I'm clipping out of the house.
I'm clipping out of the house.
Oh, I swear I got this.
What is happening?
Oh, are we not going the right way?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh you're so close, you gotta go to the right.
You gotta go to the right.
Get out of the way.
Who's this?
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
You did it, you didn't revive her.
You did it revive?
Yeah, you just threw her on the slide.
What am I supposed to do with you?
Right.
You're dragging my cord.
Did you survive?
Okay, now back up and go to the right.
We go right.
The right.
Now go to the right, yeah.
Go to the right, floor it.
Why do you floor it everywhere?
You have to commit.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay, wait.
Maybe the magazines are in our way.
Okay, yeah, it's back up a little bit and then...
It's kind of hard to see with all the fire.
Why are you still burning?
Oh, sorry.
Here.
I think we're going back to where we're at.
Okay, go right.
Oh, yeah, yeah, go, go, go.
Straight, straight, straight.
get to the left to the yeah to the left to the left oh yeah no no no wait hold up okay where are we all right turn to the left oh oh you just turned all the way around okay reverse reverse straight yeah just back up just back up back up you're good you're good oh you guys okay you guys okay I heard an alarm I think my neck is broken grandpa are we criminals now oh no we're good we're good we're good okay okay okay where am i going um uh left back up a little back up a little back up a little yeah
back up to your right go turn to your right uh turn to my right turn the wheel to the right and back up oh oh oh oh i think you're good yeah now you can oh oh wait we're at the front desk now how the hell we can either go inside or we can follow the arrows that are on the right of us i don't know oh oh oh oh oh who are you buddy who are you grandpa grandpa Good man,
is this old man Yowie?
Yes!
Guilf.
Get back in there.
Okay, both of them need to be old man Yowie.
Well, I'm old in spirit.
Oh, oh, oh, how did you almost pull up the car?
Where are we?
Wait, what happens with...
Oh, wait, showroom is behind us.
Um, Moku?
It's right behind us.
Moku?
Mugu?
I think this is a great chance to say that I'm actually fluent in Chinese and I can't be judged by my driving skills as a person.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think three of us are Asian.
And, and, and, and, and I'm, I'ma just, I'ma just for it.
I can't for it.
I can't.
Oh, no.
You guys need me.
Okay, bro.
We need you, Oimo.
We need you.
I need you, Oimo.
I think we might be mega stuck.
Oh, sorry.
No, just shake the car.
Everybody.
Just shake the car?
Yeah, shake the car.
Shake the car.
Shake, shake, shake.
Shake it.
Shake the car.
oh wait i was gonna um i think i think we're actually stuck no way no way put me in i'll get us out i'll get us out coach okay okay okay put me in put me in okay okay okay oh god i'm kind of scared now use cold boomers for 10 off gamer subs let's go boomer back in my day um horses are we where Where are we?
I can't tell where we are.
Uh, we're sideways.
Yeah, we're, like, legit on something.
The showroom is on my...
Oh my god!
I have to utilize every power!
Ah!
Wait, did I roast it alive?
Wait.
I smell delicious.
Are we okay?
Everybody good?
No, it's hot.
Yeah, we're good.
I'm okay.
It's a little tight in here, but I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, guys, I think we're stuck.
I was like, oh.
Oh, did you try moving forward?
Yeah, I tried.
Did you try moving back?
How did we even get here?
I don't know how we got here.
What did you do, Mogu?
Oh, yeah.
Did we win the game?
You could reset the checkpoint.
Oh, let's try reset the checkpoint.
How do you do that?
Oh!
Oh oh can i have the hand oh thank you thank you yeah here i'll roll the window down for you oh we're up right we're up right we're up right where are we though i can't see anything um where do we go everybody please look outside yeah the windows are foggy there's some silent back up and then go slightly right yeah i'm defrosting i'm defrosting oh you're defrosting Thank you.
Oh, oh, oh, nice.
Okay.
Where are we?
Oh, I can tell.
I can tell.
I think we gotta go left, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, are you saying that we should go left or right, Moku?
Wait, this way.
We go left?
Left?
Top left?
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
Okay.
We're literally in front of the showroom.
Yeah, I'm going in.
I crashed into it, but nothing happened.
We gotta go in.
I never get a new car.
It's almost Black Friday.
Whoa!
My bad.
Everyone good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we're fine.
We're fine.
We're alive.
Are we supposed to go in the front desk?
Whoa.
Sorry.
Oh, I think so.
Yeah, I think so.
Looks like it.
We go.
Right.
The right, yeah.
No, right now you're hitting like a white van.
Yeah, they're fine.
They won't.
They won't, no.
It'll fluff out.
It'll be, I'm going to leave.
Yeah, yeah.
It'll be fine.
I'm gonna leave the OIMO information there so that you can contact me.
Oh, good, good, good, good, good.
Excuse me.
Yeah, yeah.
OIMO will have OIMO take care of it.
Wait, I don't know.
That's the point.
Wait, wrong way.
Oh my gosh.
How embarrassing.
I think you do have to crash into it.
Okay.
Floor it, grandma.
Floor it!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wait, where am I?
Sonny, help.
Oh.
Are we it?
Look at my child!
Where'd you go?
Wait, I don't know how to get you back!
Oh, you can throw them.
You can throw them to the back seat.
No, I can't.
I don't know.
I can't reach them.
All right.
Wait, who was that?
Oh, you're back.
You're back.
You're fine.
I'm back.
I'm fine.
I'll...
What happened?
Where'd you go?
to the underside of the car uh we changed our oil so that's pretty good um i don't know where we are should i just follow the arrow that i see that says go right sure i think yeah so if i go like the world is the oyster you are the pearl of it i don't think you can go that way no i can't see what crats what crats oh it's blocked okay i think we do have to go in the showroom yeah okay okay Yeah,
you reverse in to the showroom.
You might be able to reverse in trying.
It's like a hard left.
Hard left?
Reverse.
Reverse left.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to floor it forward.
Whoa, wait, no, no.
Floor backward.
Okay, everyone's fine.
Floor it backward.
Okay.
Yeah, floor it.
Come on in.
Oh.
No?
Okay, we're still being stuck on the door, I think.
something dude i don't think we fit okay hold on okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah this is perfect this is optimal angle oh whoops wait oh oh wait it's not so optimal will it wait which way should i go uh floor wait no no no no wait wait are we making it are we are we going in i can go forward a little more let's go we're like right in front of okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay Do I go backwards?
Imagine that you're reversing into a parking spot that's on your left.
Wait, what?
Just reverse, but like imagine the parking spot is on your left.
We're reversing in.
Do you know how to reverse park?
It's mint, right?
Yeah, she knows.
Oh, we're in.
We're in.
Oh, let's go.
Yes, Sunny.
Okay, go left.
I'm trying.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I was reversing.
I was reversing.
That's my bad.
My bad.
Here, let me reverse a little bit more.
You kids.
Oh, wait, wrong way.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, am I about to leave?
Yeah, you're about to leave.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what do I do?
Can I?
Oh, go right.
Why go right?
Abby, Abby, Abby, Abby, go left.
Go left.
Straight?
Wait.
Left, but don't go straight.
If you go straight, you'll...
Oh, back up.
Back up again, and then put your steering wheel to the right.
Turn.
I'm beaming some people.
That's okay.
But my steering wheel to the right.
Wait, to the right?
You're blind them for life.
Like that.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're back in.
I think.
How do I...
and then we need to go left yeah oh i messed it up no no you didn't mess it up classic grandma yeah classic grandma oh grandma oh you you're i just not what it used to be oh oh you're cooking you're cooking you're cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm cooking you're cooking let's go Okay,
stop, stop, stop, stop!
Stop, stop!
Okay, okay, okay.
Go forward.
Don't left.
Get out of here.
I need someone to kiss my lips.
Who's turning the air down?
What'd you do that for?
Oh, grandma has bad bones!
I can't have it cold.
it's too cold in here all right all right all right oh thank you grandma thank you nice and toasty all right where do i go i mean what's so delicious left yeah oh wait uh wrong way dude these controls are so hard wrong way wrong way we're about to leave the dealership again Again?
Wait, if I go straight, will we leave?
Yeah, if you go straight, we will leave.
Oh, God.
Oh, my bad.
I think you think I'm still on fire.
Hold on.
I'll get us back inside.
Perfect.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Are we inside?
Now go left.
Okay.
Go left.
And then go left forward left.
Just a little bit forward and a lot of left.
Okay.
Yeah, just a little bit.
You're doing it.
Oh, you're doing it.
Oh, wait, gaming.
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
More left, more left.
And then...
Wait, wait.
Wait, do I...
Can you smash the window?
Oh, I think I smashed the window again.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let me back up.
Okay, gosh, this is like testing my driving ability to actually the max.
It's kind of insane.
Now nobody can say...
Nobody can say I have a bad driver anymore, right, chat?
I think I'm actually the worst one Oh, I don't think though Oh, the car We're seeing it We're fine, right?
Who's on fire?
We're okay Go left, go left Your other left My other left My other left My bed We're fine Like this way Oh, oh, oh Are we outside?
We're in the wall We're in a corner Oh, it's too high Oh, we're also on fire Night of fire
I'm melting.
My children.
My children are on fire.
Hold on, I'll make it a little cold.
Can I have it a little cold?
Thank you.
We're fine.
Everything's good, right, everybody?
Thank you.
You love hanging out with Grandma!
Yay!
Grandma!
Grab my!
When's the last time you got your license plate?
What?
When's the last time you got your driver's license?
Back in!
So it was 1775.
God damn.
Columbus sailed the ocean blue.
You were bored.
Where am I?
Okay.
You're telling us how you got your driver's license.
yeah yes i was oh wait whoa what is that okay a filing cabinet oh yeah yeah what do i do where do oh go that way go back up and then left okay good good good good good and now go all the way go all the way left yeah we got hard left everybody hold on to your Seabelt!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay.
Back and do the same thing.
Okay, okay.
I think so.
Wait, I always have to remember which way.
I do this.
Wait, no.
This?
Yeah.
Oh, yay!
Okay.
And then Floor it, grandma.
Floor it!
You're speaking my love language.
Let's go.
You're doing great, grandma.
Look at first place.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
I think you're gonna...
Whoa!
Oh!
Hold on, I'll take care of you in a second, Sunny.
I see the light.
Hey.
I'm fading.
I don't see the ending.
I'm getting dribbled.
I'm out of the sky.
Okay, you're going great.
now let's go straight straight straight straight straight straight just straight like floor oh oh my god is everybody okay yes yes yes yeah yeah oh yeah how do we how do we oh we're not in our toll oh we're toll booth oh oh where's our ticket oh do we have a ticket where's our coin oh i found a coin okay i'm done driving everybody good luck somebody else okay
Oh, I don't see any.
Oh, it says it has to be a ticket.
Oh, the ticket!
Where are we used ticket?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, we saw the ticket, but it's been gone ever since.
Oh, I see the ticket.
I see the ticket.
Where are you guys?
Oh yeah, I got it.
I got it.
Oh, you got it?
Okay.
Back up.
Back up a little bit.
Tiny bit.
Are you good?
Where is it?
Oh, so keep going.
Keep going.
Just a little bit more.
Stop!
Yeah,
you need to go forward, Grandpa.
My princess!
I love how they don't even...
Oh, wait, we're going back inside.
We're going back inside.
Okay.
Oh, this is where my life ends.
This is where life ends.
Go to the right a little bit, maybe.
Oh, yeah, we're gonna hit a wall.
Okay, go right, go right, go right, go right, go right.
No, go right.
Someone's outside the car.
That's me.
Okay, you can put me back out.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, are you guys all back in?
Right, right, right, right, right, right.
Like, what kind of right?
Hey, my Prindal is off.
Push the Prindal.
Oh, you have to put it back on.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Put it on yourself, Grandpa.
Come on, you have an engineering degree.
don't you?
Has engineering even like developed when you were like?
Girls in STEM!
Okay.
We love girls in STEM.
Alright, hard right.
Hard right.
Hard as hard as you can go.
You just have to go right.
Oh, okay, good, good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, too hard, too hard, too hard.
Okay, now to the left, to the left.
To the left, left, left.
Take it back now, y'all.
Still left this time.
Just go straight.
Okay, okay, okay.
Slowly.
Not slowly, forward.
Okay, fast.
Right, right, go right!
Oh my god!
One hour!
It took us one hour!
Oh my god!
It took us an hour!
We got it!
Only 22 bumps?
I don't believe that.
What is that?
A cane?
A new spindle?
That's a sick spindle.
It's the prindle.
Prindle!
I can't believe we did it.
We never park anymore.
We just go straight.
The spindle.
He's gotta go fast.
The mint carried hard.
I know.
No.
Mint was like the best driver.
I never expected that.
I'm pretty good at driving.
I've never had a ticket or an accident.
Oh my god, save him.
I'm pretty good.
I took my riding exam eight times before I passed.
Oh, well, the first time I took my driving exam, I drove on the wrong side of the road.
So maybe I am pretty good at this game.
Yay!
Yeah!
Okay, I guess we go next.
Yeah, let's go.
What?
What is this Simlish going on?
Wasn't it in English?
Yeah, I think it was.
It was originally right.
What's happening?
Oh, what's the stomach is that?
Sorry, guys.
I had a Chipotle for lunch.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Where are we going?
Traffic time.
Oh, we do have a new spindle.
All right, I'm going to...
Oh.
Spindle.
Oh, there's a tape in your mouth.
Oh.
here what's this one okay where am i going where are we going let's just go straight for now i guess i'm for it yeah wait actually that worked wait this is working just keep going wait just keep going
hold up what oh grandma it was a red light oh go go go go No!
It wasn't green!
That guy is...
No, no, no, go straight!
Go straight, go straight.
Okay, wait.
Are we at the light?
Um, hold on, hold on.
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
Go, go!
I think you hit a person.
No, that's a tree.
Why are trees in the middle of the road anyway, huh?
Oh, grandma, your teeth!
your teeth oh of my dentures yeah take them back i don't want to touch them nasty grandma can we go to the gun stores right there oh yeah we're gonna get hit by traffic okay i got to the divorce Want the revolver.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Hold up, hold up, don't worry about it!
Go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Oh, I think we're on a pole, that's why we're on a pole.
Oh wait, it wants me to revert.
It wants me to click on this.
Okay, I think someone else has to try.
Wait, what?
It wouldn't let me do anything.
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
Okay, good.
Go to the right a little, maybe?
Yeah, go to the right a little.
Oh, we're on another pole.
We're on another pole.
Reverse a little bit.
There's a psychiatric clinic for big thinkers.
Whose stomach was that?
Oh my god.
Bacon.
All right, go to the left and floor it.
Like this?
What's a floret?
Oh my god.
Hi!
Oh, hi!
Oh, grandpa!
Back up, back up.
I'm backing up.
Wait, which way did we come from?
We want to go to the right.
Yeah, we kind of want to go to the right.
The right.
Is that blood on mine on the windshield?
Grandma, are you here to collect insurance?
I'm going, I'm going!
Oh, oh, oh, go, go, go, go, go!
You did it, you did it!
You did it!
So close!
Wait, wait, this is good!
This is good!
Go, go, go!
Wait, um, we're gonna get...
Wait, wait!
Alright, now, floor it!
Floor it!
We were so close.
Oh, are we really?
That's gonna be fun after this.
I dropped my phone.
We're playing like the most intense frog or ever.
Oh wait, you should wait one.
Alright, and...
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wait, how?
How?
That one's tough.
Okay.
I think you can start exploring the preemptively.
oh yeah i think you have to be like really preemptive like like start going a little bit and then start rubbing yeah oh well a little a little bit go like a tiny bit go i can't just let me go what's what's happening oh maybe we need to switch again i think i think after all oh no i'm I'm missing the pedals on the car.
Oh, you have to put it back in.
Oh, this is for the...
What's this?
I'm missing the pedals for the car.
Oh, are you seeing it?
I don't see it.
Yeah, where's the pedals?
Oh, there's one.
Oh, I just saw it.
Oh, I found a pedal off the...
There you go, there you go.
Where?
That's a tape.
Why is the music so silly?
Oh, I found it.
Yeah, I was right over there.
Okay, ready?
When can I go?
Right after this.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No.
Wait, you can't even see the traffic?
Oh, who farted!
Oh, ew!
Who did that?
Ew, why is it stinky?
Oh, they've...
Roll the window down!
Ew, what's wrong with someone's stomach?
Mogu is that you?
Mogu!
Stop eating Chipotle, you know what it does to you.
Dude, I'm about to share a room with you.
No!
Go?
I can't help it!
Yeah!
We're going!
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I think we need to go to the left or right maybe?
Are we going to try it on the side?
Yeah.
I think we need to go to the left.
The left, yeah.
The right is on block.
Yeah.
Oh, back up?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
There you go, Mogu.
Oh, thank you.
Back up!
Back it up!
I'm back into the...
I think I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Wait, no, you're not.
Don't say that.
Oh, God.
I'm gonna roll the windows up before y'all dies.
That's just how it is.
I don't know where we are.
I don't know.
Who's yelling?
Who's saying expletives?
Someone have poop?
I think I fucked.
Huh?
Oh, maybe you have to drive on top of the cars.
I don't think so.
There's...
No, I think you go to the left.
Okay, we have to back up.
Yeah, we got to back up.
Back up?
Okay.
Can we back up?
Is this a front wheel or a back wheel drive?
It's a no wheel drive.
What's that supposed to mean?
Okay, I'm going to gas it.
Don't gas it, please.
Okay.
It's already pretty stinky in here.
I think we might have to restart.
How do you restart?
Yeah, the set point.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, but you have to go forward again, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
If I can do it, you can do it.
That's good.
It's overkill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Oh.
You're like my cat.
Scared the poop out of you.
All right, now go to your left i'm not gonna back up back up uh go to my left okay yeah why am i stuck oh i lost the pedal oh no oh i don't see it needs a pedal grandpa oh wait wait i think i saw it uh is that oh i see it i see it you saw oh you got it okay good good it's cold what am i doing turn to the left hard left
Yeah, don't forget.
What guy?
Hard left.
Don't worry about it.
Just go forward.
Am I going forward?
Hard left?
No, I think it's left.
No.
There you go.
Go straight, go straight, go straight.
Straight, straight.
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, we hit a checkpoint though.
Let's go.
Now to the right.
Oh, also don't forget me.
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, I'm like...
Wait, what happened, guys?
Where are you?
Wait, I'm in here.
I'm in the middle seat.
Wait.
is did i lose mint yeah i'm i'm out of the car okay no no um okay go right a little bit the print oh yeah where's the print oh i see it i see it it's not that in the front throwing this cash out oh i'm trying to reach it there you go oh oh thank you oh you just threw it up where am i supposed to go sorry right a little bit like 90 degrees forward right that way right 90 degrees yeah forward right 90 degrees oh yeah good good good oh oh the reverse okay and then left reverse yeah yeah yeah you're doing it yeah yeah okay okay no no go straight no go straight okay okay oh you might crash into the okay oh you might crash into the grandpa can you ride can you lift the the the sun thing uh no no no i can't oh here you guys could take this here oh okay i guess sure yeah that's fine i'm uh here are we there where's an ipad oh oh ipad grandpa's an ipad kid yeah there you go where's our ipad those are coco melon i don't know why do they have coco melon for grandpaws and grandma for for oh okay
so i think you just walk Oh wait, Sean, sorry.
Wrong way.
You gotta go back a little.
You're hitting a, um, yeah, you're hitting a fire hydrant.
Your mom was a fire hydrant.
Wait, aren't we supposed to turn around though?
Are we turning, are we turning around?
No, I think this is the way, right?
Yeah, we gotta, oh, there you go.
There you go.
Yeah, now go straight.
Now go straight.
Go straight?
Or turn to your left and go straight.
Like that?
Yeah, left a little and then go straight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good, good, good.
Nice!
Oh, hold up.
We got another checkpoint, so I think we're going the right way.
Oh, you're supposed to go into the park!
Into the park!
Yeah, back up.
Pick me up!
Oh my gosh, I'm in your lap!
Oh my god, muah!
Get back to you again.
Again.
Wait, how am I supposed to get back?
No, no, you're about to back into the park, so you're doing pretty good.
Okay, so do I back into the park or do I U-turn or like...
Yeah, you can probably back in.
You can back it in.
For it.
Pack that ass up.
If I back it up, is it fat enough?
No, you're moving a little though.
You might be able to.
Yeah, you might be able to.
We're squeezing in.
We're parallel parking.
Oh, we're like going the wrong way.
Oh, no, never mind.
Whoa, actually.
Okay, and then I could go straight, right?
Turn it the other way.
Ah, no.
And then turn back backwards left.
wait there's money oh there's money oh oh i see the light i see the light oh okay
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, someone's gonna poop if they, if you hit too hard.
I always hit hard.
A little bit back and then.
I, okay.
To the right and floor.
To the right, like this.
Oh, to the left.
A little bit left.
Oh, so close.
Right, right, right.
Oh wait, wait, this is still good.
It's still good.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going back.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we're going in reverse.
We're going in reverse.
reverse yeah very little very little okay nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice i can't reverse anymore on the gate we're on the gate okay okay you're so close okay we're we're so close we're like i'm trying i'm going and i'm back i'm trying oh no you're doing good you're doing Are we in?
Are we in?
We're in?
We're in.
We're in the park!
We're in the park for sure!
Grandma, the money!
The grandma the money!
Where's the money?
Grandma, we need money!
We're poor!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, who's this?
That's me!
Hi, thank you.
Oh my god!
Okay, go back to your seat.
Back to your seat.
I feel like you're the grandma from SpongeBob.
You're the grandma from SpongeBob?
Okay, where are I going?
Or?
I don't know.
Yeah, we already hit the statue.
Oh, did we?
Let's go.
That statue's right there.
There's like something in front of it.
Oh, yeah.
There was like something glowing.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, oh, oh, nice.
You can...
Whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
Suddenly it feels like Katamari.
I can't see anything.
Am I there yet?
Grandma, please.
You're sitting on my corpse.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Mwah.
There you go.
No, I'm so dead.
You're still...
It's okay, it's okay, don't tumble off!
No tumble off!
Oh, see those X's on the gate?
Wait, the X's on the gate, it might be that we hit those maybe?
Where?
Left or right?
Straight.
Oh wait, wait.
No, you're right.
You're right.
Straight.
Straight?
Yep, floor it straight.
Floor it.
Floor it!
Oh, shoot.
Well, oh, no, no, no.
Oh gosh.
Everyone's dead.
Everyone is dead.
fucking dead i'm behind you oimo hi i know sits on you sits up oh you guys are both dead like this oh where are we going it works this way um to the right oh geez so close um okay when you wait yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wait wait are we right behind it no no no it's the one that's your yeah oh like this yeah and then and then what back it up yes yeah yeah oh my gosh wait oh so close okay it's to your left now oh no no no okay back it up oh there's a tree okay oh wait go to your right quite a bit and then floor it what like this like this yeah yeah yeah Good angle.
Good angle.
Great angle.
Okay, where am I?
Back it up a tiny bit?
Reverse a little.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like a little bit.
And now- Oh, good girl.
Oh, this is good.
Yeah, to your right.
A little bit.
Yeah, a little bit.
Can I ride a little bit?
Forward right?
Yeah, forward right.
Oh, my tummy.
Like this?
Okay, now floor is straight!
Floor is straight!
Floor is!
Wait!
Whoa!
Now- Did I not make it?
No, you did!
Is that not what we're supposed to do?
Is there the other exit that's over there on the right?
I'm missing a pedal.
Oh.
Yay!
What pedal are you missing?
I got it.
Am I there yet?
Am I doing good?
I don't know.
Do we need more gas gas gas He's one of you guys that's shooting.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to think my power movements can't control the sound something's going on in here Oh, your seat's down.
I think There you go.
There you go, buddy Where am I supposed to go I think go straight.
Oh Where am I?
Am I going straight?
Oh.
Yeah, go straight.
Go straight and a right.
Right?
Straight and a right.
A little bit to your right.
Oh, I keep pressing the...
Oh, I did my left, sorry.
No, it's okay.
Don't say that.
It's not okay.
You're a great, you're doing great, sweetie.
I'm gonna floor it.
Hold on.
Floor it.
oh my god yeah there's i see that you guys i see the exes yeah it's weird is it like where the building is on like behind us you're like a pamphlet we're supposed to be i feel like this pamphlet is supposed to help us is it what does it say yeah read it sorry oh i'm just there you go it just it says like don't miss this park statue which is where we were local lowdown the model pipe and loop back beneath the statue etc etc what what huh yeah they give you information wait so we need to go to the statue then okay there's something underneath the statue yeah there was like something glowing yeah is that why we're locked in because we don't have to loot we have to loot the statue let's get to looting okay there's a statue you're right in front of it no way okay pour it girl oh no no no no i see it oh back up yeah yeah we're backing it up we're backing it up back that dumpy up mint okay now a little bit to your left and then forward okay okay good good good good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay now make keep going a little bit to your left and forward just keep going little by little oh good good good good Keep going, keep going.
More left or forward?
Just forward.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, I think the statue is literally right in front of us.
Oh, wait, I think I see something.
Oh, wait, do we see the glowing thing?
Yeah, I think whatever's glow in there.
Okay, forward.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Are we there?
Back up just a little bit.
Just like a tiny bit.
Just like...
Oh, yeah, gold pipe and bag.
What?
Oh, do we just take it?
Yeah, take it.
Take it.
Grab it!
Oh, what's going on?
I can't grab it.
You can grab it.
There's a button.
Oh, there's a button on the bag of money.
Oh, there's a grab the money.
Get the money, get the money.
Press forward a little bit.
Forward a little?
Just a little bit.
Like point point?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, perfect.
Go ahead.
Someone press it.
We can't seem to press it.
Okay, you try.
I can't reach.
Do we have to, like, grab it from the...
There's no way we can grab that, right?
Guys.
I thought this was a driving game, not a problem game.
Did you grab them?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I get it.
Did you get it?
We're gonna...
Here's a pedal.
I'm gonna...
Eat!
Okay.
What's that glowing thing on the corner of the park too?
What is happening?
God, my grandson looks so stupid.
I'm sorry.
I got it from you My beautiful daughter should have never married that ugly guy Oh my god damn Why can't I roll the windows down?
Why is there blood on the windows?
Yeah, there's blood on the windows You can't roll it down I can roll it down But how do we It says it's missing the bag of money How are we supposed to get the bag?
drop wait there's something golden in front of us do you guys see on the left yeah yeah i see i see grandma go straight and a little bit to the left and we put it on top and a little bit to the left yeah yeah you see it's missing the loot right now am i still still left uh it's still a little bit left like like this please stop throwing paint do you see that there's a loop back there that's I can't see.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
A little bit left and forward.
It's on top of the trash can.
It's like literally top left.
Oh, yeah, you're so good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's something glowing.
Oh, yeah.
I see something.
Move a little bit to your left, grandma.
Oh, uh-oh.
I can't go in here.
Can we run over the tree?
We ran over a lot of trees.
Wait, let's see.
Wait, no, no.
I think you have to back up a little bit and then go left.
You might have to back up a little bit.
like yeah yeah and then go forward oh go a little bit right yeah to the right okay just a little bit oh it's so close it's so close bro why don't you why don't we just get out of the car yeah i know i was literally gonna say that can you get it can you get it no it's no it's like literally it's like that thing where you have to grab it from the side and you're right in front of it oh my god and then gotta go like a little bit to your left and then okay don't floor it i'm not okay okay keep going a little bit forward inching a little bit to your left and then forward.
I won't let me go left anymore.
Hold on.
Oh shoot.
Okay, hold on.
Why can't we just go outside?
Okay, now go left.
Yeah, I know.
Like 90 degrees.
Oh, you're so close.
I'll do that again.
Do the same exactly again.
Same thing.
Okay.
This is tough.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Ow!
They're fine kiddo, you're fine kiddo, you're fine kiddo.
Buck it off.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, back up.
Oh my gosh, the way it spins too much.
The wheel spins too much when I back up.
It messes me up.
Oh, oh.
Are we okay?
Everything good?
Everyone fine?
Everything's good.
U-turn.
A U-turn.
Yeah.
Do you remember what a U-turn is, Grandma?
Oh, yeah.
You can just U-turn.
Yeah, I can just U-turn.
Okay, okay.
I'll do it.
I'll just U-turn.
Okay.
You're so smart.
Yeah.
It's so simple.
Am I U-turning?
Do you not know what a U looks like?
Take it.
Let me go back to the other.
Oh, no, this way, this way, sorry.
Oh, no, it might be over.
No, it's not.
How do we do the checkpoint thing?
Oh, no, we're good, we're good.
Oh, no, we're gaming.
We're gaming.
Okay, go straight.
Go straight.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're gaming.
It's literally right in front.
Hey.
Wait, I got kicked out.
Sorry.
Okay, let's go.
Forward.
I want to see what you guys are talking about anyway.
You're good.
I'll loop it to your right.
Oh, there's a tree in the way.
Oh, wow.
It's like shiny money.
the garbage did you get it no i can see i'm so close which way which way it's covered by the tree back up no it's not back up back up can you guys reach it no i can't reach it back up and then go forward a little bit back up keep backing up yeah yeah now turn to your right and go forward yeah yeah
oh wrong way right and then forward yeah now forward yeah Yeah, forward.
Yeah, yeah.
And to your right.
A little bit to your right.
Okay, okay.
We're close.
Oh.
Okay, back up a little bit and then go right again when you go forward.
I feel like...
Is it a collectible or is it for...
To progress?
I can't tell.
I just think it's to progress because you have to put the money on top of the bag.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
You just turn to your right and you'll be able to see it.
You see it, Mugu?
I see it.
okay sharp right I believe in you that's not right okay forward and a little bit to your right no you passed it you passed it where am I grandma grandma you're in heaven you're dead oh okay we're gonna an hour for each level oh where am I Oh, you're like right next to it,
but you're far.
Okay, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, you see it?
You can see it off the front.
Oh, you're good, you're good.
Now forward, forward, forward, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Like, like, like this.
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, so close.
We might be in my way.
Okay.
I can't reach it.
Oh, who is this?
That's me.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, get in the back with the rest of us.
Oh, we're getting further away.
Hmm.
Right?
No, I think it should back off a little.
Where is it?
Oh, we're getting farther away.
Yeah.
Oh, so.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Back, back, back.
You're good.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, oh, oh, no, no, no.
Hey, someone else died again.
I'm outside the plumber.
Don't worry about it.
We need to get the money.
Yeah, we need the cash.
Don't care about.
Oh, oh, oh.
We literally wait, oh my gosh, wait if you back up we'll get it.
We'll get it.
Oh, just back up straight Oh, someone is someone laying the hawk is someone honking at us in the park?
Like we're bad drivers.
Oh, I wouldn't let me reverse.
Okay.
Oh, you're like right.
Yeah, turn to your left actually if you turn if you go No, never mind.
Yeah Let's make a sharp left.
Super left and go straight.
Oh.
Not left enough, maybe.
Wait, wait.
Oh, I think we're actually upside down.
Oh.
Wait, what's happening?
Are we still upside down?
Yes, we are.
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Go straight and to your right.
Oh.
What's happening?
You're in front of the statue.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, okay, I can't see.
Come, Mojo, I believe!
Come, Mojo, go!
Oh, I can't close.
Forward, go forward!
Now floor it.
Floor it forward.
I don't see it.
Yeah, you're doing great!
You're doing great!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Oh, it's so close.
It's so close.
Is it in front of us or is it behind?
It's in front, right?
Yeah, it's in front.
It's in front.
It's in front of them.
Just go forward a little bit.
Like edge the engine.
Oh, guys, I feel so good.
Keep edging.
Can you get it?
I can't reach it.
No, no, no.
Oh, wait.
Up, up, up, up, up.
Back up a little tiny bit.
Back up.
Yeah.
Okay.
Mokisa, so stressed.
Okay, now forward, now forward.
Just go straight.
Okay.
Straight into the right a little bit, I think.
Okay, jade to the right.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, edge it.
Oh, why can't I even- Oh, stop, stop!
Wait, wait, I can't reach it!
I can't reach it!
I can't reach that, I can't reach it!
No!
I'm breaking!
The fucking bench!
Oh.
What?
What, what, what's next to it though?
Yeah.
Unless the game wants it to be like pixel perfect.
That's crazy.
Oh.
Okay, we're going to drive out of here.
I think there's an exit, right?
There has to be.
No way.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Can I get it from this way?
It's like a drive-through?
Hold up.
What if you...
Yeah, like a drive-through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can't reach.
It's too far.
It has to be so close.
I can't reach it.
coins at it?
Oh, oh my god, what if you have to put the coin inside the...
No way.
Okay, okay, okay, I think I...
Just go forward, edge it.
There's no way.
Edge it?
Stop, stop, stop it!
You see it?
Okay, a little bit more, just a little bit more.
Can you grab it?
I can't, right, grab it.
Can I grab it?
Can you grab it?
Uh, is there?
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna lower my windows.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
my god why are we shaking okay here you guys go oh okay i think we need to we need to put it in front of the yeah we have to put it on the statue yeah no way forward and right okay we're so close you're doing good you're doing awesome i love when the windshield wipers just come on yeah yeah that's very like old oh god oh oh oh oh oh i see it it's like flashing red now it's like Beep,
beep, beep.
Give me money.
I need the money.
Where's the statue?
Then we all need money.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Are we close?
There's like something collision in the background.
It's going crazy.
Oh, there's the cars, I think.
A little bit back.
Okay, back up to your left.
Okay.
So go right, right?
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, kinda...
Back up more?
Just keep... Go back up straight.
Uh...
Okay.
Just straight up back up.
And then stop?
Oh, okay, okay.
And then go forward.
Just go forward.
Straight.
Uh, I don't know.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
Straight in a little bit to your left.
And then... Okay.
A little bit.
Just a little bit.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Keep going, keep going.
Edge it.
Oh, you're so close!
Let's go.
Okay, stop!
Stop!
Okay, I took that.
Moku's throwing.
Oh!
Moku, that throw is this for us!
Oh no!
Do you get it?
No, no, no, no, no.
I can't do it again, Moku.
Go forward a little bit.
Okay.
Okay, one more.
Just one more time.
Okay, I'll- One more time and...
Nope.
One more time.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Right here!
Yeah!
Wait, what's happening?
What's it doing?
Oh, he broke it!
He broke the gate, I think, back there.
Oh, yeah, he did!
But what happened to the statue?
I think it fell and, like, broke the...
Oh, yeah.
He, like, dashed.
Oh, to the front!
You're at the game!
Right, right, right, right!
Right, right, right, right, right!
Hard, right?
Uh...
Right, edge it.
I will, I will, uh...
Why do you keep saying edgy?
It seems to be working.
Look here?
Oh, oh!
A little more, a little more, a little more.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Go, stop, stop, stop!
Go right, straight.
Right, straight, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, straight.
No, you're gonna run into the wall.
Yeah, a little bit.
A little bit this way.
So clear.
Okay, back up.
Okay.
So, okay.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, you see it?
You see it?
Oh, no, no, I can't see it.
Okay, I'm gonna.
To the right a little and floor it.
Oh, not enough to the right.
We're gonna run it to the wall.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
It's always Mogu that gets us into this situation.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't...
Oh.
Um, you know what?
I'm gonna do this.
Okay.
Oh, wait!
We're out!
Go for it!
Floor!
Go straight!
Just go!
Don't stop!
Don't stop for anything!
Just go!
Don't stop!
Just keep going!
Okay, so close.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
At least that goes straight.
No.
Oh, right.
Oh, wait.
That's going to floor it.
Go, go, go, go, left, left, left.
Left, left, left.
You ran over the cop.
Okay, go right, go, no.
Go straight.
Go left.
Oh, God damn, he's dead.
Someone died?
Oh, nice.
No, that's my body.
Next to the cop.
Oh, shit.
Who's honking?
Hey, who's honking at me?
Hey, I'm driving here.
I think it's the cop.
It's grandpa.
Wait, if you back up, you'll hit like five people.
It'll be really...
Oh, there they go.
There they go.
Mint!
Yeah!
Oh, we ran into a hole.
Keep going?
And we ran into a tree.
Force it, force it, force it.
Force it?
Okay, a little bit to your left and then go straight.
Yeah.
Okay, go straight, straight, straight, straight.
Good, good, good, good.
Go, go, go, go!
Let's go!
Let's go, let's go!
Oh my gosh, this is so beautiful!
I'm gonna drive slowly so that we don't flip.
Slow!
Who cares about going slow?
Oh, checkpoint!
Floor it!
I'm flooring it!
Oh my god, this is such- oh my god, we made so much progress.
We really did make so much progress, man.
Yeah, we did.
We might- we're almost close, I think.
Oh.
Right and then forward.
That's the last thing in the pamphlet.
to go to what's the pamphlet where are we marvin's mystery meet oh i see it's right in front of us oh we're gonna flip there we go nice oh i think we went in the water yeah there's a bridge here oh just go go who cares about traffic oh wait why are we reversing why are we reversing oh i think the bridge starts going up or something maybe so you just have to keep going just keep just keep going just keep oh we did it and a break maybe oh oh oh there's traffic right in front of you oh my god okay good that was so close go go go go go go oh oh oh maybe or what's happening it wouldn't it made me click on the the oh maybe it like periodically forces you to to the chain yeah yeah go oh go Oh,
here you go!
Am I safe?
Just answer your question.
Tell me when!
Okay.
Win!
No, no, no, no!
This part is always so hard.
This part's difficult, yeah.
This part's really hard, yeah.
Wait, am I on reverse oh you're going back wait uh i lost my prindle where is it on my team oh thank you oh i can't grab it can someone there grab it there we go okay oh oh where oh where are we go go go crash that cross it Go.
Oh my god, we're getting it.
We're going, we're going, we're doing it!
We're doing it!
Ah!
I didn't know there was a second intersection.
Oh, it's hot.
Are we okay?
We're okay, team.
Don't worry about it.
We did.
Yeah.
Just this one left.
Oh, whoops.
Oh wait, you're back.
Sometimes it puts you in reverse for some reason.
Okay.
Oh, oops, sorry.
I tried breaking.
The brake pads are like so bad now.
Oops.
We gotta get into this.
We're on fire again.
Also, there's no brake pad because there's no brake.
Yeah.
Here's your brake.
It's in, it's right here.
Oh, that's why.
Wait, can you throw it again?
I can't get it.
I don't know where is it.
Oh, let me, let me get it.
That's why I wasn't breaking.
I'm trying to get it.
I can't get it anymore.
Oh, oops.
Um, I'll just go straight then.
Oh.
I love this version of frog.
I hate it.
I don't know, I found the tunnel.
It's up, it's right up there on the left.
I can't get it.
Oh, yeah, use the windshield wiper.
Windshield wiper?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Where are you?
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
Like, 720.
Wait, oh, wait, that's the Prindle.
Oh my gosh, I need to break you guys.
I can't get it.
Oh, right here, right here.
Oh, I tossed it into the front seat.
The front seat floor.
The right seat.
The passenger seat floor.
I can't reach it.
I can't see it.
Nope, that's a windshield.
Or that's the window.
Mintz is the lid.
The lid.
What lid?
What are you talking about?
What's the lid?
Oh, it's right there.
Oh, I see.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I see gravity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throw it, throw it.
Throw it.
Oh, you're desperate.
That's my teeth.
There's a black thing.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, hold on.
Oh, oh.
You know what?
We're just gonna...
It'll toss it around until it comes back.
Oh, I found it!
It's like it!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my god!
Wait, what is this?
What is this?
It's in the front seat, past it, like, from the floor.
I thought that was it.
I can't get it!
That's my thingy that...
I got it!
Hold on!
Oh, oh, I got it!
I got it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh finally!
It's with the lights!
Okay, tell me when to go.
Okay, good luck.
This is the hardest one.
Start now.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Hold up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold up!
We did it!
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, back up, back up, back up.
This way.
Yeah!
Baby!
Oops.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, go!
I'm insane!
Are we going through the drive-through?
There's a drive-through?
Yeah, forward, right?
Oh, right.
What if I went inside?
Okay.
Hold on, you want chicken nuggets or what?
I want chicken nuggets.
Be patient.
I will.
Yep!
Yeah!
Wait, do I need to keep going back up?
A little bit.
And then right.
Go right.
A little bit and then go through the driveway.
We gonna have chicken nuggets!
Like this?
Yep, keep going.
Then go straight.
Just like two steps.
And then- Yeah, yeah, yeah, perfect.
And then like- Now what?
Forward and left?
Left?
Oh my gosh, like we're actually going through- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Checkpoint.
I want a little toy.
Okay, perfect.
Stop.
Right?
No, go straight.
Straight.
Just go straight.
Okay.
Wait, where do we go in?
What does it say?
I'm so hungry.
Drive through Slop!
I see it!
The Slop!
Yay!
Am I going still?
Just like two steps.
Two steps.
And then luck.
And left.
Oh my god.
She's so good.
Oh my god!
Order here!
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
I can see it!
Oh my god, is that why we need the coins?
Hello.
I think someone needs to...
Could I get a...
It's up down?
Oh, oh, oh.
Why does it look like a...
Hello?
I went up, I went down, I went left, and I went right.
Do you...
Do I pull up more?
No, there's a car.
Guys, order.
Did you guys order?
Um...
Why do you get him?
Are we supposed to throw the coin?
A coin at them?
Or is there something else?
I don't see anything.
I could throw a coin too.
Can I get some fries?
I have some...
You're the one who's driving.
Oh yeah.
No, it says pay here, like over there though.
So I don't know if we're supposed to pay here.
Hmm.
Did I do it?
I'm gonna swear at him.
I'm Canadian.
How do you swear?
Where?
A space bar?
No, mine's telling me.
Wait, wait.
Um...
I have a mixtape in my mouth.
Get it off me, Grandma.
Oh.
Teach me how to swear!
Oops!
Oh, it needs to have the mixtape in your mouth.
Here.
Wait, you have to?
Yeah, to swear.
Yeah.
No, I'm not there.
How do you put it up?
No, you need it in your mouth.
What is this?
But how did you put it in your mouth?
Is this like a blinker?
I think you have to shove it in.
No, we don't need those.
I need to shove it.
The mint has to shove it into your mouth.
What does this do?
Maybe you have to be closer to the window to order.
Do we?
Do I have to back up?
Back up straight and then make a slight left when you go forward.
Yeah.
Um, could I get a six piece nugget?
Meal and do.
Oh.
Okay.
I really want chicken nuggets now actually.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, wait, we can actually order.
Oh, we can order.
I'm getting, I'm fooding.
Oh, I'm feeding.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, chicken nugget.
All chicken nugget.
Why is he shaking his head?
Why does anyone- I want chicken nuggets sir?
they're going we're out we're out hold up what is there like an order we have to do do we have to do left right i see i see drink burger fry try that drink burger fry order from top to bottom drink burger oh drink oh my god oh okay drink burger nope drink
Drink burger fry!
Okay, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
Okay, ready?
No, I got it.
I got it.
Drink burger fry.
No, no.
Drink?
Yeah, we can go forward.
Oh, we can?
We didn't even let us get chicken nuggets.
They didn't even let us get chicken nuggets.
They said pull forward.
Let's go.
Okay, now it's Kobe.
Kobe time.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm pretty sure.
I can pay.
I have a point.
Are we good?
More?
Yeah, I'm good.
coin right now i have my order wrong i'll crash out yeah yeah perfect perfect perfect perfect two coins two coins okay oh a little bit more a little bit more a little bit more a little bit perfect yeah okay go go one there's another is there another oh oh uh i don't have one you don't run kobe um i see your coin in the front oh i see it right here i see it right there do you see it Let's go next to grandma.
Next to grandma.
Why can't it?
It doesn't reach.
Do we need to hand it to him?
I think you just hand it to his hand.
Okay.
Where's the coin, though?
Do we use all the coins?
No, they respawn.
They respawn.
Oh, wait.
They're in the front seat.
Can you give it to him?
You got him?
Do I have to go closer?
Do I?
Back up and then be closer, maybe.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, they want you to be really close.
how this whole game is they just they have to be super oh that's so good is it good no way okay and then he needs a steering wheel oh a steering wheel yeah he needs a steering wheel How do I give that to him?
Uh, right click the steering wheel, maybe?
Oh, okay.
No way.
Can you give it to me?
Uh, oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
It dropped out of the car, and now I don't have a...
Wait, did it...
Oh, I did it respawned.
It's fine, it's fine.
Here, I'll give it to you guys, I'll give it to you guys.
Okay.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
There you go.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, no, I got it.
You got it?
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, how am I supposed to drive?
The guy, the guy is still asking for a steering wheel.
oh no we responded we're gonna die we're gonna die this is literal hell this is this is a
gas it gas it i have no steering wheel okay oh i guess you just gotta go forward because there's Wait, I have it in park and I can't move.
Oh, yes, I can't.
Oh, God, I can't see.
Let's go, whoa.
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
I don't know what's happening.
Where am I?
What's happening?
I don't know.
I just see colors.
I can't see anything!
I'm a little...
I think we just have to get out.
How do we get out?
On the right, on the right.
I can't see you.
Where's our food?
We have to eat it.
Oh, are we supposed to eat it?
We were supposed to eat it.
Oh, we eat it.
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
Oh, pizza.
Guys, I have a pizza.
Is there a steering wheel in the car again?
Oh, it's a pizza.
Pizza.
Oh my god.
Here, here, here.
Grandma, use the pizza.
Oh, the pizza.
Oh, my.
Wait, this is so evil.
Wait, it hides how much your wheels are turned down.
No!
Oh!
Evil.
Where do we get out?
Where's the out?
Oh, I see it.
We have to back up.
It's on our right.
Or you're closer to reversing out.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, like this?
Yeah, yeah.
Keep going back.
There we go.
Oh, we had a checkpoint.
Oh, nice.
We're not done yet.
Oh, my God.
I know.
Kill me.
We're not done.
Please, I'm done with this.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Help us.
Please, please, please let me leave.
Put me out of this misery.
I don't even know.
Oh, trip.
How is that the checkpoint?
What are we supposed to do next?
I think you're supposed to- It's just what's the last thing we need.
What's the last thing we need?
Oh, no, no, no.
Uh, I see it behind us, behind us.
Do you see the alleyway?
Oh, I remember the go- The alleyway!
This is port point.
Oh, no.
Where?
Uh, wait, can we- I'm gonna reset.
Wait, reset, restart checkpoint.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Where are we?
Do I just go forward?
Go forward?
A little bit?
I turn left.
Oh yeah, there's a shortcut in the alleyway.
That's not fast.
Turn...
Which way are we supposed to go?
Left.
And then left.
What the hell?
Oh, it's forcing...
It's forcing me to switch with one of you.
Wait, we have an engine!
A check engine error!
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Good luck!
oh oh oh oh grandma hello i just couldn't get enough of being in that seat oh just a little bit more i like how we're electing for zoos oh my god this is so difficult wait this is gonna be so tough okay oh my god Oh, shit.
No, hard right, hard right.
Wait, 1-800-555.
I'm always hard.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, grandma.
Grandma.
You don't have to get ready if you stay ready.
Oh, shit.
This is so hard.
Oh, my God.
We're good.
It's so difficult with the pizza.
Wait, is that the owl?
Oh, I want to go to the dinosaur store!
Oh, the dinosaur!
A Tyrannosaurus red!
Wait, that's so smart.
That's okay.
Okay, to the left, to the left!
I'm breaking.
Oh, I was like, that's why I'm not breaking.
Okay, we're back to the checkpoint, I think.
You could just restart at the checkpoint.
You wanna like to the right?
Or left?
Left?
Oh, no, no, no, okay, okay, yeah.
Go straight, straight, straight.
I'm gonna eat some food.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah twisty twisty oh shit now this way right right right you're doing good yeah yeah backing off oh my god i'm doing i'm gaming i'm locking in no this is you're really good holy oh my god oh my god nice yeah that was awesome okay okay it says road closed where do i go left or right oh my god we can't see i don't know i can't see You just gotta go straight.
Okay.
Oh wait, I think this is actually...
Yeah!
No way.
Check us another hour.
I love that average speed is three.
Three?
Three miles per hour.
We're crazy.
Response 28.
We respond 28 times?
Oh my god, chocolate bar.
Chocolate bar.
Our whole car is becoming food.
Oh, we're in the subway?
We're at the subway.
Oh, this kid looks traumatized.
How long is the day?
I'm thinking up in Ben Manaka.
The kid be like, why was he in English before?
No, he's not.
Yeah, I know, right?
Alright, grandma.
Okay, let me drive through this.
subway.
Drive through the subway.
Prindle.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Am I cooking?
You're cooking.
Just go straight.
Wait, hold up.
This is kind of cool.
Yeah, good.
Good.
Yeah, this is good.
This is good.
Oh, nice.
To the right.
To your right.
There's tickets.
There's a pedestrian.
Hit him.
Oh, there's a pedestrian?
Where is that one?
Hit it.
To the right, to the right.
To the right.
Straight and right.
Straight.
Yep.
Right.
Yeah.
Wait, where did he go?
Like that, right here?
Oh, a little bit more.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, wait, wait, yeah.
Oh, we do need to buy the ticket, though.
Wait, actually, it's stop here.
How do we buy a ticket?
Damn, I made it right on time.
Hold up.
Oh, wow.
I gotta take it.
Oh.
Take it.
Oh, I have to put the...
Oh, oh!
Oh, oh, wait, oh.
I'm gonna roll my window down and tell him he's gonna die.
You're gonna die!
We're gonna get you!
You're next buddy!
Am I not supposed to put it in?
Is it in?
Ah, Does this say anything?
This doesn't say anything?
I'm gonna look for it.
You want me back up?
It's just...
No, no, no, it's perfect.
It's perfect.
I just can't find a coin.
Oh, we need a coin.
There is something glowing.
behind us yeah there's a bicycle behind us do you want to go back yeah let's check it out let's check it out just like a little bit go back a little yeah do you see the glowing bicycle it says buy your tickets I'm pretty sure we're supposed to like this what is this bike for oh I see the coins are in the front we escape from grandma's wrath and we ride the bike home
I don't want to go on the third rail.
Yeah.
What's the third rail?
You wouldn't like it.
It's how you turn into a ghost.
If that's where you guys are, then I would gladly become a ghost.
Song is kind of bopping.
Okay, okay.
Go forward.
Just a little bit.
Yep.
Okay.
Stop.
Do you have the coins?
You got it?
Oh, oh, oh.
I...
Yeah!
I missed I missed I can't see Oh, it's in the front Grandma, it's on the front Oh, do I toss it?
Yeah, try tossing it on your end How do I know if my window's down?
You roll them Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's down It's like really obvious when it's up Okay Oh, I missed Like this It'll work Oh Did it?
Oh, wait, I heard something.
Oh, I think so, I think so.
Oh, did I go forward now?
To the right.
Forward and to the right.
Forward first or right first?
Forward?
Both at the same time.
Like this?
Yeah.
Wait, what's that written on the wall over there?
Do I go forward now?
Wait, what does this say?
Yeah, forward.
It's like shining.
long.
Left.
Oh, we gotta put it in the... Yeah, we gotta put it in the... Oh, God.
Another little... Yeah.
I'll take this out of my mouth.
I'll take it.
Take it out with your mouth.
Just use your arms, forehead.
Like this?
Am I cooking?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just give...
Put the ticket.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Where's the ticket?
I don't know.
What is the ticket?
There's a coin.
There's a mixtape.
Mixtape?
Is this a red thing?
No, that's probably not.
No, that's in the instructions.
Where did the ticket go?
Who has it?
Did we get a ticket?
Did we?
I don't even see this magazine thing.
Another coin.
I don't see a ticket.
Did we get a ticket?
IBS.
There's nothing in the glove compartment.
Wait, uh, Dusty, when you threw in the coin, did it give you a ticket?
I got no idea.
It sounded like something happened, though.
Should I back up and try again?
There was like some music, right?
Yeah, there was like...
There was something...
Yeah, yeah, it made like a sound.
Something definitely happened.
Yeah.
Otherwise, we all wouldn't have thought that it worked, I think.
Oh, wait.
Was that just the subway?
noise noise no you guys hear it well back it up all right grandma's gonna buy a ticket grandma i don't want to drive anymore i'm dry what do you mean i'm the one who's driving where's the ticket thing i can't see to the right i mean sorry to your left other other right yeah yeah yeah oh you hit him you hit oh he's so dead he's so dead i want to see what this I see it,
it's like behind us, right?
Or where is it?
This is your left to your left, yeah.
Back up a little bit.
Gotcha, gotcha, back up, back up.
Stop.
Okay.
If beyond.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Wait, wait, wait.
This might be perfect.
Give me a cool one.
Give me the cool one.
There's this two right in front of me.
Grab it.
Grab it and give it to me.
Do it.
Do the thing.
Roll down your right now.
Wait, can you back up?
like the tiniest bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like this?
One more.
Uh, you're not backing up at all.
Oh, it's on neutral, my bad.
Like this?
Yeah.
One more, one more.
Okay, perfect.
Wait, is your window at all?
Is it?
Your window's not down.
Your window is not down.
Bye, babe.
Here you go, babe.
Oh my gosh.
It's like, I think it's got to be pixel perfect.
Oh no.
I can't even see.
Can you guys press up and then see?
Like, wait, wait, wait.
If there's a hole?
Yeah, there's a hole.
There's a hole.
Oh my god.
Come on, every hole is a goal.
You're hitting like the... You're hitting the top.
Do I need to go inside?
Oh, I got it!
It dropped the ticket on the... Oh, I got it!
I got the trade ticket!
Oh, yay!
Good, good, good.
Okay, now where do I go?
Where do I go?
I want to back off a little?
Back off?
Back up?
Yeah, this way.
I want to go to...
Where are we going?
I want to go to a maid cafe.
Yeah!
Wait, can you keep backing up like crazy?
Like all the way?
I want to see what this says.
Oh, stop now?
Oh, okay.
There's like a secret!
Can you pull forward just a tiny bit?
Okay, let me put Mogu back there you go.
You can...
Move forward a little bit?
Oh yeah, there is a secret.
If anyone would like to buy me a new B-phone or a banana ink second skin virtual reality.
Headset.
You can find me under the bridge.
I am the one wearing a jacket made of old magazines.
Thank you.
Okay, that's all I wanted to write.
Easter egg.
Where do we go?
Buy him a new phone.
To the left.
All the way to the left, left, left.
To the left, to your left, left, left.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, wait, stop.
Oh, oh, oh, never mind.
wait oh there's another one yeah there's a second one go back a little bit go back a little bit
like this like this yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and then what and then street a little bit inch No.
Inch force?
No?
No.
Oh, right or left?
Wait, I don't, I can't see anything.
What are you guys doing?
What the fuck?
No.
Oh, now you can go forward.
Oh, you're perfect.
You're perfect.
Yeah, now you go forward.
I know I'm perfect, baby.
Edge, edge, edge.
Edge, edge.
to the hang right hang right hang right oh good good good you're so good oh my god stop stop stop oh back just a little bit back yeah just a little bit back yeah oh yep a little more a little bit like a little more there we go oh perfect did we did it did it work you do it oh no okay get tickets put your tickets in oh do we have to get closer oh my god it's one of these maybe someone else do it it's on the seat it's on the seat Um...
I think we have to be closer.
Okay, so you want me to back up a little bit and then go right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Turn to the right.
Like this?
Okay, to the forward.
Just forward or do you want me forward right?
Forward right.
Like that?
And then more.
A little bit more.
Like that?
A little more.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're getting- Yay!
Woo!
You're gonna go to your right and then- Can you go to my right?
Right and then go to the left.
Ooh.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
The key is blinking.
Oh, yeah.
You have to switch or something.
then yeah okay let's go let's go okay left left left left left left yeah yeah yeah there we go No, you're good.
Keep going forward.
Okay, good.
Just go forward.
Just keep going forward.
Keep going forward.
This way.
Why is it so slow?
Oh.
Oh, the pedal fell off.
The pedal fell off.
Oh, wait, is the pedal a chocolate bar?
Oh, it is.
Our whole car is turning into candy.
Yay!
Oh.
Ow!
Oh!
Hi, Moab.
Oh.
Good job, team.
Where are we?
No, you're going to office direction.
Oh, you're going backwards.
Where are we?
Why can't I go?
No, no, you're going the wrong way.
You're going the wrong way.
You're completely going the wrong way.
Yeah, you're going the wrong way.
Yeah, turn hard right.
Turn hard right.
Yeah.
Like super hard.
Rock hard.
Oh, come on.
Bo-go, bo-go.
though we know hard right hard right hard right okay okay not hard enough oh my god oh no i'm i'm oh my god everyone i am out of the car oh i am out of bounds okay nice okay now back up straight and then go right go left turn the other way when you're backing up yeah there you go you're perfect there we go now go back up back up back up back up no no no no we hit a checkpoint oh where are we what did i do what did i do oh go straight now and to the oh i'm freezing
thank you okay do you go to the right what do we do now let me defrost my windows okay now for itch form a little bit and then turn right hi chili i'm dust
oh uh turn right turn right oh oh wait wait wait uh i'm sorry man here you go that's not me but thanks
Where are you going?
Yeah, there's so many arrows everywhere.
Okay.
I think it's like, you have to go in there and it's like a little bit, not a maze, but kind of like a snake, you know?
It's like a snake.
Oh, a solid snake?
Wait, did you have a break?
I don't need, I don't need one.
I did lose it, but I don't need one.
That's okay.
You don't need the what?
Yeah, you go.
The break.
Oh, okay, cool.
yeah just like we don't need windows yeah we only need each other where do we go okay to the left where where bogu was going and then backed up and then but then it says there's like a right my arrows are saying to go left i don't know where i'm going we go inside there we go in there we go yeah we go in there okay oh there you go oh there you go oh no no no no no i'm sorry i'm sorry Are you guys on fire?
Oh, yeah.
Well, I'm just dead.
There you go.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Okay, so you need to turn around.
Okay, wait, maybe I do need my break.
You guys need my break?
Where's the chocolate bar?
Oh, it is a chocolate bar?
It's a chocolate bar.
Uh, I don't see it.
I don't see it.
Oh, I see it in the front seat.
Oh, I see it.
It's in the front.
Okay, now I'm back.
Nice, nice.
I see it.
Okay, go for it.
The break.
No, no, no, don't go forward.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is that not the way you're going?
Yeah, keep going.
Yeah, now turn left.
Turn left here.
Okay.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's those line thingies.
Like at this point.
Oh, no, no, no, stop, stop, stop, stop.
No, no, you missed it.
You missed it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Moku, actual old version.
I know.
I know!
I thought, dude, I thought we were playing a game.
I didn't think it was that immersive.
Moku no Moku no I don't think you're in the right way I grew I grew Moku I grew Moku Okay Okay Okay Yes turn left Turn left And forward Left and forward Okay Am I turning left?
Chad Am I turning left?
I don't know anymore Okay It's hard The pizza makes it harder It does It does Because you can't see your wheels anymore Okay Okay Wait this is fine though Keep going left you'll turn around okay oh my gosh it is a good boy oh wait no no oh there you go oh close close close oh i can't see anything i can't see anything no we can't either
okay am i supposed to super frosted or is it super hot it's hot it's hot it's hot it's hot yeah you need to make it colder there you go oh too cold too cold let me know good good I put the windows down I'm calling for help help me sos all right back up back up straight and then you'll go to your right you'll turn up make a hard right yes back up straight back up straight back up straight just a little bit more just a little bit more okay all right now hard right hard right turn it as far as you can to the right don't floor it was that as far as you could yeah right right right right right no no no no okay okay okay okay i i see i see grandma sees grandma sees oh yeah i believe in boku grandma i believe i believe if i ever go visit you i hope you're not picking me up from the forward a little bit then go right i'd like to go back in the car thank you i can't oh well i don't see your dead body anymore no no i'm back oh good good good good good good go right right right right and forward
right yeah yeah right right oh wait wait wait wait stop oh yes back up a little oh yeah just a little bit uh like a teeny tiny no oh stop break break break i got another four four four oh my god are you kidding me oh nice nice nice oh we're great you're doing good you're doing good okay now go left and then tiny yeah oh why are we why are we reversing
vogue you have to do this this is your challenge that you must be Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, no, no, you're giving.
You're giving.
Just a little bit more, just a little bit more.
Am I, wait, why can't I go straight?
Because you're bumping into the rail.
You have to go back a little.
The rail.
Just like a little bit.
Okay.
You're so close.
Okay, now stop.
And go to your left, hard left.
Oh my, wait, really?
Yeah.
This left or this left?
What?
Your left.
closer left like forward forward left forward left oh you
have to do this this is you you gotta do this this is your training this is your training this is your training you can do it oh shoot okay go forward left yeah yeah yeah good good good oh nice nice now back up oh no no no no throwing that okay perfect perfect okay nice you just have to go left okay now go left hard left hard left like mega hard so if we ever are together your other left right that's counterclockwise right guys oh my god oh no oh no oh no oh no okay back off a lift oh no if you have if you have to put up your hands and you hold up,
your right your index finger and your thumb and then the left hand will look like an L and the right hand will look like a backwards L.
Yeah.
Oh, wait wait.
You're doing it.
I don't know how about you.
I don't know.
No, no.
No, she.
Oh, yeah.
She didn't.
Go right.
Yeah, go right.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Go forward and right.
Move it to your right.
Just a little bit.
Like a smidge.
like I don't even think she needs to go to her right yeah oh yeah go straight yeah go straight floor it floor it oh okay now go make it right where you go right make it right make it right make it right yes yes okay yes okay go straight straight straight good good good oh my god oh my god oh my god okay I need to the wheel a little bit to your left a little bit to your left and it's- Oh no no no no no no!
No please no!
No!
No no no!
I'm sorry!
This is so bad!
This is so bad.
Yes yes yes.
Okay, okay.
And then reverse the way.
No no no no!
Do the same thing, do the same thing as before.
Go forward and left.
I don't think she knows what she can do.
Oh.
Oh, no, we had the perfect turn.
We had the perfect turn.
Yeah, you were doing so good.
I need a pee over your back.
I really need to piss myself.
Okay.
Just a little bit backwards.
Yeah, just back up a little bit.
Just a little bit.
I really want a spindle.
Oh, I found it.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wait, hold on.
Okay.
You're going to want to go...
Hard left and straight.
Left?
Right.
Oh, sorry.
Hard right, right.
Hard.
But back up again, yeah.
Yeah, and then...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hard.
It needs to be harder.
Harder.
Okay.
Hard.
Oh, okay.
When you...
yeah yeah oh oh wait what okay oh geez a little bit good good oh my god you're gaming yeah you're gaming okay okay and then and then a little bit back like a little bit yeah a little bit back okay okay stop stop stop stop and then stop stop stop and then like yeah yeah turn hard right Hard,
hard, hard, hard, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, yeah, yeah, that was so gentle, where are we going?
Okay, a little bit back.
No, no, you're so close.
Yeah, you're really close.
You're really close.
Oh, I have to turn left here.
Yes.
Oh, I don't think you're going to...
Are we there yet?
Oh, other way!
Other way!
Actually, I think you can just back up.
Back up.
Like, go back up straight.
Yeah, just back up.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Keep backing up.
Like turn it the other way and back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Straight, straight.
Hit that guy.
Kill him.
You're gonna die today, mister.
I hope you enjoyed your pizza.
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
Okay, now go forward, forward, straight, but a little to the left.
Left, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Turn.
Yep, there you go.
Keep turning, keep turning.
Yeah!
Okay, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop, stop, stop.
That was on purpose.
Get your ass out purpose.
You're gonna go straight and hard right.
I'm going to wear the lines as Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're so proud of you.
Nice, nice, nice Nice, nice!
Oh my god.
Right, right, right, right, right!
I don't have to see my edge.
I was like, wait.
Oh.
Wait, how did you do this?
Wait, uh, she parallel parked.
She parallel parked in this.
You're so close.
Mogo, you got this.
You got this.
Mogo, Mogo, go.
All right.
Mogo, Mogo.
Mogo.
Okay.
You're gonna need to reverse turn.
Yes.
Okay.
Not- You know how to K turn?
What?
Other way, I think.
Right?
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
No, no, you're...
No, the other, the other...
Turn the wheel the other way, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, there you go, there you go.
And then go, okay.
Yeah, yeah, and then...
Or...
Oh.
No.
Okay, back up, back up.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Just straight up back up.
Yeah, straight up, straight back up.
Nope, that's not straight.
Oh, wait, that's good, that's good, that's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, you see a tunnel?
You see it?
Go in the tunnel.
I can't go in the tunnel.
Yes.
To the left, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Back up.
Okay, okay, yeah, no, make a right.
Make a left, make a left, make a left, make a left.
I know, I know.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna...
How are you doing this, Moko?
I don't understand.
Moko!
Moko, you're so close.
Just trust me.
You know like those things where you try to put the key in the door and keep missing you?
Oh wait, you're so close.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Why?
Why did you prefer?
I didn't even...
I was like, oh, let's go!
Girl, girl.
What?
God, girl, what the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait.
You're saying, you're- you're- you're- your Prindle, your Prindle!
My Prindle.
Right there, right there.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, I- How do you keep doing this?
I know, right?
Okay, where- where's the- Okay.
Okay.
Oh, it's too cold.
It's too cold.
I can't see you.
Okay, so what are you gonna do?
I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be right back.
Okay, okay, okay.
Make a water test.
I need you to do a donut.
Where is it?
Okay, okay, okay.
No, okay, it's right there.
I'm gonna turn the other way.
Okay, okay, okay.
and then and then left no okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay back up a little oh no i think okay okay okay okay okay okay no no no go forward okay oh just forward yes put the wheel back straight i don't know I don't want to kill a bad street.
Yeah, okay, you did it.
Yeah, keep going, keep going, keep going.
I don't know, nothing's happened.
You keep going, you're doing it.
You're not controlling it.
Okay, never mind.
No, no, no, go back on.
Okay, go on.
Oh my god.
Maw, go please.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, you did it!
Yeah!
We did it!
Okay.
Yay!
Okay, now you have to back up and then go right.
Okay, can someone find my brakes?
Brakes.
Ah, brakes.
I think it's in the passenger floor seat, like floor.
I can't reach that.
I'm not tall enough.
Oh, just like press your, press the D key.
I think you can like lean.
There you go, can you reach it?
Ah, that's a mixtape and that's a- There you go.
Found it, found it, okay.
Okay, need you.
You just need to back up straight.
Just a little bit.
And then I think it's right.
Stop, stop.
And then go right.
Yeah.
Now go straight.
Straight.
Yeah.
Good job.
Good.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't care if I die today.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh!
Who was that?
Oh no!
Okay, I'm driving again, I guess.
Dusty, old lady driving.
My way.
I think you have to like avoid the, what's uh, I found the Prindal, I got you.
It's over the, it's, uh, like, um, I got you wait i got you hold on i got you we might be gaming oh never mind i don't wait oh we don't need the print oh hey grandma what just happened the train came isn't that so cool every three minutes oh it's every three minutes where am i uh we're both i don't know where we are i'm dead Oh,
I'm alive.
Mint's definitely dead.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Mint's been chilling.
She's...
She's been chilling.
I can't move.
Yeah, I can't either.
How do I go back to the checkpoint?
Um...
You doing okay there, Mint?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm one with the dash.
Dash up the dash.
I think we're up the ceiling.
How do I...
How do we go back to the checkpoint?
Because I can't turn.
Oh.
Uh, here.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
So I go left or right?
You go right.
Right.
Oh, I'm missing the prindle.
Oh.
Uh...
I got it.
Throw!
Thanks.
Me?
Oh.
There you go.
Eh.
Okay.
So I just go forward and right, right?
Yeah.
Forward and right.
Be careful of the train.
Um, here comes the train.
Destinians.
Oh, can we just have the train go to the left?
Push us forward?
Like this?
Oh, no, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hang right.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, go forward.
Now.
Go forward?
Oh, it's not going forward.
Oh, oh, here comes the train.
Here comes the train.
Oh, this is impossible.
No, this is actually impossible.
This is impossible.
I won't do this.
I won't satisfy their games.
I'm why how does this do this this is the worst oh my god okay okay maybe you can push us forward oh my god oh to the left
it alternates left and right track so it's like um the worst oh
it's the worst it's the worst the fuck is happening Okay, you want to ride to your to the left side of?
I don't have my Prindle anymore.
Oh.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Here you go, Grandma.
Thanks, sweetheart.
Grandma, why do you look so hairy today?
Hairy?
What?
You speak to your grandma like this?
I can't move forward for some reason.
Uh oh.
Wait, is the Prindle not?
Wait, do you have your gas pedals?
Oh, your gas!
You're missing the gas!
Oh, where's my brake?
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
You got it?
There you go.
I got it.
Okay, I'm going!
Let's go!
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go!
The left?
Hug, no, hug the right.
Wait, are we actually supposed to do that?
Yeah!
What?
My steering wheel!
Okay.
Where am I?
live i we're at top of the track i just see a black screen but i can tell we're alive what uh i can't see anything i can't see anything i can't see men i could see you are you guys dead okay yeah you guys oh how do i reset oh restart checkpoint right yeah yeah yeah exactly oh okay i have my breaks my prindos here okay let's get going let's go right Wait,
why didn't you turn?
Oh wait.
It's over.
It's hard to...
I'm ready to die.
Wait, you're going the wrong way!
You're going the wrong way!
Slop.
That's what this game is.
Yeah, it is.
It's supposed to be a flop.
Wait, you might be...
Forward, straight!
Forward, forward!
Grandma!
Grandma, you're grabbing me, not the car!
What?
see anything actually um the we can't see anything oh time to die oh there you go oh thank you wait can you make it warm in here oh no go backwards oh oh oh oh yes i don't think we're gonna back through this guys no no wait can i try yeah you can try the switch change places oh change places yeah well you're missing the break If I wasn't before...
Um, I don't see it, Baku.
I don't see the crate.
I rolled down the window.
Did I ever tell you guys that sometimes at drive-throughs, I rolled down my window a little bit, and I just whisper, help me, the best dude.
Baba hates when I do this.
Why would he hate it?
I know, right?
He tells me to stop doing that.
Here I threw it to you.
You did?
Yeah.
That was your gas.
Oimo, the train is coming.
Oh, it's over.
Oimo, we're going to get run over.
We're going to get run over.
Grandma's going to get run over by a reindeer, except the reindeer looks like a car.
Am I not running?
Where am I going?
You got to put the gas pedal on.
You're also running into a wall.
Wait, I already have the gas pedal, though.
No, that's your brake pedal.
No, the E is a gas.
Yeah, I already have an E on.
Oh, I have another E.
What's the other way?
That's so stupid, gaming.
You gotta reverse and turn to the right.
Yeah, remember, Oima doesn't know how to drive.
Okay, I think I'm better than mobile.
Oh!
I'm gonna go on a drive.
I think I'm stuck.
I'll try after.
You know, I don't want to do this part though.
I'm legitimately, wait.
Am I not stuck?
You are stuck, yeah.
You gotta turn back.
You gotta go hard right now, hard right.
Forward hard right.
Hard.
Hard rock.
They're not coming yet.
Harder, harder, harder.
Harder.
Now hard right.
Changing her way.
Harder.
Harder right.
Like the hardest, you're just going straight back and forth, sweetie.
You're really good.
Wait, who's in the seat now?
It's me.
I'm Vento.
Save us.
I don't want to do this part.
I don't want to.
Okay, I think I got shot.
Wait, are we...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way, my bad.
And then you can reverse.
Let's just reverse back.
Yeah, we'll do it backwards.
We'll just do it.
We'll do it in style.
We don't look at cool explosions.
The only thing cool that I like to see is in this car already.
Where's the train?
It'll come.
Oh, wait.
Awesome.
It always comes.
Oh, shit.
I think that was me.
I'm sorry.
I lost my Prindle.
Can someone please give it to me?
I think I see it.
Oh, dear Prindle.
I see it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Did anyone grab it?
I don't know.
You told me to grab one.
And did anyone grab my break?
We're still alive.
It's behind me.
It's on my butt.
Oh no, it's on your butt.
Why are you shoving up your butt?
You're not supposed to hook that.
Sanitize that first.
Did someone give it this?
I got it.
Now I need my break.
Break?
Break.
I see it by...
I see what we're doing here.
I got it.
Where is it?
Is it that?
Yeah, I got it.
Wait, you got it?
Here you go.
Oh, thank you!
Okay, let's do this again, baby.
Only for the most beautiful grandma.
Okay.
Oh, wait, oh my god, you're so good at this.
All right.
Tell me when to go left or right.
Just say, oh, whoops, whoops.
Left, left, left, left, left, left!
I'm trying!
where am i wait oh my gosh we're almost out of bounds holy cow back at the entrance it's coming again i think oh my god it's so difficult it is i don't think we're going to get through this part everybody but that's fine okay grandma it goes straight okay you're going great go straight okay good good good oh my god They're so good.
They're so good.
Very straight.
Left, left, left.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, is this pattern right now?
No!
It's over for us!
It's okay.
There's another train coming right.
Maybe I'll see.
Oh, it reset.
It reset.
Oh, it pushes way back into the entrance.
Why did it do that?
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
Good, good.
Okay, okay.
Okay, nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's cold.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
I didn't do that.
I swear, this car is haunted or something.
For real.
Ghost car.
It's like there's two ghosts in here or something.
Like, what the hell?
Oh, my God.
Why would that happen ever?
That's, like, the rarest thing ever.
That's crazy.
Try to drive a car.
Yeah, it could never happen.
Okay.
Sorry.
I know I'm driving a little erratically.
Okay, here we go.
I think, oh, no.
and I are also probably dead.
Left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Yeah, I think this is pattern recognition.
It's always left.
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, we went past the first part.
Uh, we need to, back up, hurry, yeah, it's like, oh, shoot, I went the wrong way.
harder the the rotation on this part is ass
okay go straight go straight go straight and then left yeah oh we did it oh oh what's happening no uh okay no what do you mean no oh i'm in your lap hi Wait, where do we go now?
Go straight?
Oh, it's a bunch of boxes.
No way.
Oh, this looks so awful.
Okay, go a little bit to your left.
And then, no, back up.
Back up.
And then go a little bit to your left.
Why can't we just run over these boxes?
Yeah, why can't we just...
Those fucking boxes are just filled with cinder blocks.
My bad.
Oh man, is this truly hell?
Yeah.
Which way do I go?
Left.
Left?
Yeah, because there's a box right in front of you.
Oh.
Is there a way to go around?
Oh, you have to go around these boxes.
Oh, I gotta go around.
You might have to back up.
Yeah, back up and then a little left.
Back up straight?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, sorry.
So sorry.
It's all the pizza.
The pizza.
OK, move a little bit to the right because you're okay.
Oh, perfect.
I think that's good.
Okay, there's a ramp.
There's a ramp.
A ramp.
A straight, push straight.
A floor.
I'm going to bump up a little bit.
No, don't go back.
Are we good?
Oh, I think they're all ramps.
I do this all ramps.
um are we are we facing up we're facing the ceiling we are are we are we are facing the ceiling um we fell off the round can you go i'm gonna reverse oh geez i think we might have to restart it No, don't, don't say that.
You can salvage it.
Salvage it.
Okay, okay.
I believe in my wife.
I'm stuck.
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Maybe a little bit more.
Oh, okay.
What is it doing?
Keep going, keep going.
I can't.
You keep placing the...
Is that letting...
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
That's good.
Wait, hold on.
Let's try.
Let's try this.
Okay.
I go straight or go left like this.
And then when I back up, I go like this.
Okay.
I go like that.
Yeah.
I must live.
Yeah, see the plan.
Okay.
Oh.
It kicked me out.
Good luck.
I don't think I can see us.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck, everybody else.
Who's everyone else?
Us.
Oh, is that Oimo?
It is.
Do you want to come back to him?
No, no, no.
Is it moving at all?
You're toast.
No?
What?
Because I'm backing up, like, full speed.
Yeah, it's kind of tricky.
Oh, you're definitely not moving.
Oh, yeah, we're, like, right on top of something.
Oh, I think we fell off.
Are we restarting?
I have to go soon, though.
I have a meeting in a couple minutes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, whoa.
This game is hell.
I never want to touch it again.
Why did we say this would be fun?
It was fun with you guys.
Thank you.
This game was also really hard too.
It was hard.
It was fun because we did it together.
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
I think it was fun because you guys were playing.
Friendships makes a game.
Friendships makes the sloth, you know?
Are we kind of the same thing?
Oh wait, I can shoot it out to people's mouth.
Give me, give me, give me, give me, I want to eat more tape!
yay thank you guys thank you i'll see you guys soon yeah i'm gonna i'll head out then okay love you love you bye bye-bye bye bye bye bye everyone could you explain thank you thank you i love you all bye-bye bye-bye what what did the score say what did you say oh she's back what'd you say hold up i said um you're sometimes like we're bad at leaving calls sometimes we just have to leave at the same time oh that's true that's true but i i love you you have to go meeting yeah that's all the reason Bye!
It's true though sometimes.
Just go and I.
Just go and I will watch Common Rider together sometimes.
And then when we're trying to end the call, we'll be like, Love you, love you, love you, love you, love you, love you.
So, yay!
This game was hard!
This game was so stinking hard!
What the heck?
Oh, I have none of the customizations.
Oh, my god.
Good morning, Ryder.
Ah, but I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys did too.
That was craziness.
Minto, kawaiiya.
Fun group though.
I hope you all play something together again.
Yeah, originally we were going to play that RV there yet game, but I think all three of them had already played and Apparently the map stays the same So it's only me that hasn't played it before Thanks for the nifty and fun driving lesson.
We learned things Yeah, hold on let me make sure VB and Vicky are okay Okay, I got to record some stuff
Okay.
But yeah, I still had a lot of fun, even though the game was very challenging.
It put my car driving skills to, like, the absolute test.
Now, nobody can ever say that I'm a bad driver again, because I felt so powerful.
I felt so powerful.
The Minto stays busy.
How does she do it?
Two meetings in one day.
She's insane.
How does she do it?
Yeah, I have like...
Wait, what time are we meeting?
Am I crazy?
Where is...
Oh my god, we're meeting in an hour.
Oh, I was like, oh wow.
Do I have like four hours of meeting today?
No, we're meeting in an hour.
Oh.
oops well that's okay i can get some rest for a little bit actually i have some stuff i need to do before the meeting too so you were legit doing great with driving blind thank you thank you yeah time to speedrun i can i can handle it i can handle this whole game the power of friendship got us thrilled friday whoops saturday night
a meeting.
Good time to rest for a bit.
Yeah, I think this is the most I'll have to rest today, so.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will see you when I see you next.
I'll see you later.
Tomorrow is karaoke.
I'm excited.
We can just, uh...
That will be pretty chill, I think, too.
Yeah, yeah.
I have just a few things that I need left for debut.
I'm waiting on some stuff to come in the mail for me to use.
I have to record some things tomorrow.
But overall, oh my gosh, you guys, I'm such a genius.
There was one part of something that I was making that was like the most daunting for me.
And I was like, oh my gosh, am I going to be able to do this?
Am I going to be able to complete it in time?
And then I came up with another idea and I was like, yeah, I'm so glad I'm a genius.
I'm so glad I'm a genius karaoke is there going to be an announcement yeah the announcement will be that you should come watch densitsu.exe on Friday
but for real now I'm gonna head out so thank you so much everybody it was a long long day of streams for me so actually well no I'll talk about this later oh I was gonna mention something but it's something I kind of want to talk about uh during my during on friday i feel awkward calling it a debut so thank you so much for the thank you thank you okay for real now for real what's a minto everybody thank you so much what's a minto bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you thank you